there's an app for that wait hold on I'm
Steve
Jobs don't stop it it was a phase so
ubiquitous in the early days of the
smartphone craze that it's hard to
believe Apple actually has trademarked
it was a testament to a simple and
immutable truth about the world these
new touchscreen phones were creating no
matter how strange and obscure the need
there would be an app to fulfill it
perhaps you remember iBeer the app that
allowed you to pretend you were drinking
a a tall glass of beer for some reason
there was car M an app that reminded you
where you parked your car in a pirate
voice and who could forget I am bread a
surreal game about controlling a
sentient slice of bread on a quest to
become toast but there's one app out
there somewhere on the market that you
probably didn't download and if you did
well you have our sincerest apologies
because even seeing this video pop out
onto your feed probably sent a chill
down your spine well if that chill ever
even left take it from one gentleman
whose life took a very strange turn
after downloading a certain app that the
SCP Foundation calls SCP
1471 because the sentiment there's an
app for that doesn't exclude
experiencing mortal Terror Joe Lis an
insurance salesman from Milwaukee had
just gone through another atrocious date
after a mediocre meal and an
uncomfortable 35 minutes of an Ang
Babble sensing the whole time that she
really wasn't that interested his date
excused himself to take a quick phone
call outside sadly for Joe she never
returned leaving him to pick up the
check of all the many words you could
use to describe Poor Joe Lis the most
pertinent would be lonely ever since
Carol his wife of 10 years had passed
away in a freak accident he'd been
trying to find some kind of way to fill
the void they'd been high school
sweethearts intent on spending the rest
of their life lives with one another as
fate would have it only Carol would get
that tainted luxury Joe would be forced
to endure life after the joy of living
had run its course he only hoped he
might be lucky enough to find love again
however Joe was on the wrong side of 40
and as so many others his age were
already hitched he could feel his
options going out one by one would he be
destined to live out the rest of his
days alone Joe didn't feel like spending
the back half of his life catching
reruns of Seinfeld and tending to his
fish he needed to get out there and
thankfully like the rest of us he lived
in the internet age he had more apps
websites online services and hot Russian
singles in his area than he knew what to
do with so surely one would have the
right person for him he tried them all
Tinder hinge match.com Plenty of Fish
e-harmony Bumble zus Okay Cupid
FriendFinder deeply lonely singles with
low expectations. comom and so much more
more however all it seemed to achieve
was setting him up for more
disappointment none of the dates he'
managed to get ever resulted in anything
getting serious heck it was a minor
miracle if he even managed to get any of
them on a second date was this it was
this his life now had he only ever
gotten one shot at love and the grasping
claws of Fate yanked it away from him
without a second thought would life
continue on the hamster wheel of
loneliness sleeping getting up eating
working and sleeping again every day
getting somehow both faster and slower
as life trudged on to a disappointing
yet inevitable conclusion what a
terrible fate to find yourself trapped
in whenever Joe started feeling modlin
like this he knew it was time to get
proactive again maybe the right woman
was out there there were billions of
them after all surely at least one of
them would be the perfect person for him
he just needed the perfect app he'd burn
through all of the most reputable apps
already and was now perusing some of the
slightly seedier options most of which
were likely data mining fronts from the
Vulcans however as generic app after
generic app passed something different
caught his eye the icon was a smiling
cartoon dog and its name was Malo
version
1.0.0 this gave him a little chuckle at
the very least it was very different
branding from the rest of the dating
apps he'd seen maybe it just been sorted
into the wrong section of the App Store
he decided he'd check it out and take a
look at the app's description the
description read never settle for those
awkward feelings of being alone ever
again Malo is an exciting and
interactive experience that will keep
you engaged and intrigued the anxiety of
social situations can be nerve-wracking
but after just a few hours of malow you
will soon forget all about those painful
emotions of disappointment be part of
the new craze that is quickly becoming
the next social substitute remember the
more you participate the more Malo will
engage you your experience is completely
up to you absolutely no ads enjoy well
it certainly provoked Joe's curiosity at
the very least he did want to banish his
feelings of loneliness and seeing as the
app was free and apparently had no ads
he'd surely be foolish to not at least
give it a whirl what's the worst that
could happen he began the installation
and only then noticed that the app had
no listed develop ER it took up 9.8 MB
of memory which he wasn't Tech saavy
enough to see any issues with more than
anything Joe was just enticed by the
prospect of finally having another
chance at companionship with Malo after
all it is the next social substitute
whatever that means however Joe's
excitement was quickly quashed when he
hit the home screen button and noticed
that the icon for the app never actually
materialized strange he checked the App
Store portal again and saw that
according to them the app had completely
downloaded what gives was it a glitch or
was Malo actually just malware either
way he was disheartened by the fact that
this immaterial app certainly wouldn't
be getting him any companionship or so
he thought anyway Joe was used to
disappointment by now so he didn't take
it too personally he decided to just
play out the rest of his evening on
autopilot making himself some soup doing
the laundry watching more Seinfeld
reruns taking a cold shower and
preparing to himself to sleep again Malo
was already becoming a distant memory
just like all the deceptive sources of
home but one strange thing happened that
disrupted Joe's finely tuned evening
routine he received a text message this
was incredibly strange because nobody
ever seemed to text him the last text he
got was from Carol just before her
accident so it was almost sural to hear
that alert sound now after everything
that happened he checked and saw that
the text was was an image attachment
sent from an unknown number perplexed
yet curious he decided to open it his
curiosity soon gave way to a kind of
melancholy Nostalgia when he saw that
the photo was of his and Carol's
favorite Cafe in town they'd spent many
a morning there back when she was alive
treating themselves to a nice cup of
coffee and perhaps a Quant just seeing
it again caused an involuntary smile to
spread across his face it never even
occurred to him as it probably would
have to others that this could be seen
as a little creepy he hadn't frequented
the bakery since Carol died how would
anyone even know that this place held
any significance for him was it a
stalker a ghost or just a spooky
coincidence none of these thoughts even
crossed Joe's mind he was just grateful
for the surprising reminder of the
happiness he'd once had for the next
couple hours things seemed lighter he
went about his evening checking the
photo every so often and smiling until
eventually he found himself in bed still
looking into the glow of his phone it
was such a beautiful little cafe then he
froze he noticed something in the
picture it'd been there the whole time
but only now he was seeing rather than
just looking it was in the corner
staring through the glass of the cafe
store so faint he almost wanted to
dismiss it as a trick of the light it
was a face well not a face more like a
skull not a human not anywhere near
human long slender and canine with
protruding fangs and vacant white eyes
the Pure White of the skull was buried
in a nest of thick black hair it looked
like it was crouching behind the door
looking out and grinning whatever the
hell it was just seeing it changed the
entire tone of the picture it was no
longer a simple reminder of bygone Joy
now all that was radiating out of that
image was a palpable sense of dread was
someone playing playing some kind of
awful prank on him just then he was
jogged from his contemplation by another
alert a new message from the same number
as before with great hesitation he
hovered his thumb over the push
notification and clicked that's when
everything got a lot worse it was a
photo of a bus stop not just any bus
stop of course it was stop c16 the one
that Joe always took to get to work it
looked like it was taken relatively
early in the morning but nobody was
there
well not quite nobody there was that
figure again it stood at full height
behind the partially frosted glass that
makes up the back of the bus stop the
same large black humanoid shape with a
white grinning dog skull where the face
should be something about it terrified
him on such a primal level like the way
our lizard brain reacts to some ancient
apex predator and whatever this thing
was it clearly knew something about him
how else could could at stage all these
photos Joe got out of bed and looked out
of the window down onto his dark Front
Street empty thankfully but after this
surprise nightmare he wasn't going to
take any chances he grabbed a kitchen
knife from downstairs and placed it on
his bedside cabinet right next to his
phone with 911 on speed dial Joe Lis a
43-year-old man slept with the lights on
that night for the first time in over 30
years sadly for him the nightmare was
just beginning the next morning Joe woke
up unharmed but he wasn't pleased to see
that he'd gotten several more texts in
his sleep there was one taken outside of
the local insurance company office where
he worked the strange creature with the
skull for a face was looming around the
corner peering at the camera with its
lipless grin like it was mocking him
another photo was taken at the local
supermarket where Joe did most of his
grocery shopping the frame was
centralized on the seral aisle bordered
on both sides by walls of garish mascot
dos endlessly repeated down at the far
end of the aisle was a looming dark
figure with that cold canine skull where
a human face should be there were a few
more but worst of all was the last one
it was taken at the cemetery in the
foreground a headstone reading Carol Lis
beloved wife and daughter Joe was
horrified to see that skull-faced Beast
was rising up behind his wife's grave
long clawed fingers curling around the
top of the headstone that was the moment
that Joe decided to go to the police
about all of this before things got even
more out of hand he called an Uber to
get down to the station he certainly
didn't feel like he was going anywhere
near his regular bus stop after last
night he showed the photos he'd been
sent so far to an officer posted at the
station and they agreed that there was
certainly something strange about it
while the behavior undeniably bordered
on harassment it hadn't yet delved into
criminal territory so he would sadly be
on his own until then the best they
could do was stay in touch and kept a
breast of any new developments the only
Sage advice they could give him was not
to delete the photos as they could
always be used as evidence in cord later
if things escalated this was literally
the last result that Joe wanted out of
this considering how bizarre and
threatening things were getting already
he really didn't want to find out what
escalation looked like in this case but
what else could he do but carry on just
trying to exercise as much caution as he
could in these strange new circumstances
he went to work and tried his best to
stay productive despite the fact that
every 3 or so hours a new photo would
arrive places that he liked to sit in
the local parks stores he'd frequent
restaurants he liked to eat at the
nightmare skeleton dog thing would be
standing in all of them just mugging for
the camera on one hand every time he
looked at one of the photos Joe felt
like he was giving this freak exactly
what they wanted on the other hand how
could he possibly Look Away what if he
missed something that could save his
life it carried on much like that until
later in the evening Joe may have not
been a genius but he was no fool either
he'd seen too many of those CD true
crime documentaries about kidnapping to
take his normal route home he took a
real detour frequently checking over his
shoulder the entire time much to his
relief he didn't see anything out of
place good when he got home he locked
every door and bolted every window
nothing would be getting the jump on him
tonight that's when the next picture
came in a photograph of Joe's empty
office cubicle with the Bony face of the
creature looming over the divider with a
grin he could feel his heart pounding
away in his chest just looking at it how
did this thing get around like this how
was it able to infiltrate everywhere in
his entire goddamn life suddenly he felt
a smile spreading across his face this
freak had just messed up big time before
before all these creepy photos had been
taken in public places but the one taken
in his office oh this crossed the line
into trespassing the police would have
to do something about it now it had
given him an ace up his sleeve that
confidence faded a few hours later when
he received another photo this time it
was the skull-faced monster just
standing on the sidewalk the sidewalk
that Joe remembered walking on his
covert alternative route he could feel
himself break into a cold sweat his
seemed whoever this was he really did
hold no secrets from them now more than
ever Joe didn't feel safe in his own
home so you can only imagine how he felt
when a few hours later he received a
photo of the skull-faced stalker
standing right outside his own front
door staring into the camera it sent him
rushing to the window again to check
outside but of course nobody was there
the next day when he called the police
and updated them on the situation they
told him that they were doing all they
could the best thing he could possibly
do was to remain calm but Vigilant he
needed to keep an eye on the photos
being sent to him so he could notify
them if ever he was in any immediate
danger this put poor Joe's paranoia at a
fever pitch even when he went to work
surrounded by his co-workers by
Witnesses he could scarcely tear his
eyes away from his phone he was a slave
to the photos forever waiting for the
next one only to experience crushing
regret when the photo actually arrived
it looked like it was taken moments
before it was sent to him Joe saw
himself looking at his own phone in his
office cubicle with that huge
skull-faced figure looming behind him he
screamed out loud upon seeing it and
turned to see if anything was behind him
but of course there was nothing there
the police inspected the office talked
to potential Witnesses and analyze the
photo it showed no signs of any
photographic manipulation but there were
also no witnesses around the office who
claimed to see anything strange that day
there was also no security camera
footage in the last several days that
showed this figure coming in or out Joe
lilis started to feel like he was going
insane and perhaps he was but that
didn't change the tangible and
everpresent feeling that he was in great
danger he didn't come into work the next
day he'd received more photos like that
in the night of himself taken in real
time time with that skullface freak
looming he didn't want to leave the
house he didn't want to go anywhere
anymore he just didn't feel safe out
there how could he with all this madness
unfolding there was a time where he
could have said something like at least
it only seems confined to my phone he
might have even suspected that it had
something to do with that strange malow
app he downloaded a few days prior that
hadn't seemed to do anything but this
situation had evolved since then he
wasn't just seeing the creature in
photos anymore it was here he kept
seeing quick flashes of it on the other
side of Windows in Reflections in the
corner of his eyes always darting away
if ever he turned towards it it was
everywhere and nowhere it was here just
for him he just knew the police couldn't
help nobody could help Joe just sat in
the corner of his bedroom clutching his
kitchen knife afraid to close his eyes
it could be anywhere it could be
anywhere it could be anywhere we know
one thing for sure Joe Lis never felt
truly alone ever again he always had his
new friend waiting just out of sight and
if ever you're feeling Lonesome and
decide to download Malo version 1.0.0
yourself then you'll never feel lonely
again either have you ever seen
something you weren't supposed to
something that made you feel off
something you regret Secrets like these
are best kept to yourself but since
you're still alive whatever you saw
wasn't nearly as bad as what Peter
Holland saw one fateful night in January
of
2015 Peter was an unremarkable man an
office worker slaving away at The Daily
Grind and like a lot of people Peter
enjoyed nothing more than coming home
after a long hard day kicking back and
watching some TV it was this innocent
activity that led to Peter's horrifying
brush with SCP
5049 altering the course of his
otherwise average life forever the event
started at around 10:05 p.m. Peter was
channel surfing glued to the couch in
his sparsely furnished apartment
commercials commercials commercials as
far as Peter's tired eyes could see he
paused for a moment to watch the end of
an ad for a car he could never hope to
afford on his salary but something
stopped him from changing the channel
again the next ad had begun and it was
playing a strange scratchy jingle that
gave Peter an odd sense of unease but
even Stranger Than That was the text on
screen demon Dan's Discount homunculus
Depot in baby blue bubble lettering he
forced a smile this had to be some weird
comedy skit or viral marketing campaign
or maybe it was something he drank but
no this was a real commercial and things
were about to get even weirder the pepy
Lo faded to a concerning sight a tall
humanoid figure dressed like a used car
salesman but one that definitely wasn't
human his skin was dark green and
covered in patches of thick fur he had
long fingers with intimidating Claws and
a grin full of needlelike fangs it
looked almost demonic and after a few
seconds the demon began to speak hey
there folks it's your man demon Dan
coming at you with the latest and
greatest deals from demon Dan's Discount
homunculus Depot we've just accepted a
shipment of brand new models that would
make even the most Discerning customers
weep with excitement let's see what
we've got the creature apparently named
demon Dan stepped away from his desk
revealing two long furry goat legs that
ended in large pointed Hooves Peter now
assumed he really was going crazy but at
this point he was along for the ride
demon Dan continued his pitch looking to
make your way through the capitalist
hellscape that makes home look cozy come
try one of our newest businessman models
Dan gured behind him to where Peter was
horrified to see a total of 52 adult
male human bodies hanging from a wall
there was something uncanny about them
they seemed almost Hollow like a highly
realistic costume or a prop from a
horror movie Peter didn't have much time
to think about it though as demon Dan
went on if you're looking for an extra
challenge of inequality the
businesswoman model may be a right fit
for you the commercial then revealed a
wall of human female bodies strung up in
a similar fashion now you may be
thinking but Dan business sounds H I
just want to have some fun and the fine
team here at demon Dan's Discount
homunculus Depot have got you covered
the camera zoomed out to show an area of
the store filled with children's
decorations and more of these strange
hollowed out human suits in child sizes
to match any who has more fun than kids
no one that's who for a limited time the
purchase of child siiz unit comes with a
complimentary 50% off coupon for
parental units you just can't say no to
a deal like that before Peter could
process the madness that was unfolding
before him the camera cut again the
store's logo appeared on the screen once
more along with several cuts to
locations around the store itself there
were more human bodies hundreds of them
demon Dan's sleazy voice rang out over
all of it here at demon dance discount
humongous Depot we know it's not all fun
in games the bravest Among Us have a
mission to accomplish the seven Lords
are ever planning their Invasion after
all so you're looking for function over
form well we've got that in Spades down
here in the Tactical Services Department
you'll be kicking ass in no time when
you're wearing the latest models at the
best prices seven Lords Invasion what
did any of this mean suddenly the camera
was showing him a new room red curtains
parted revealing more of these person
suits several bearing a striking
resemblance to real human celebrities he
managed to make out Gucci M AAL LaVine
Paul McCartney and Britney Spears before
demon Dan's appearance once again drew
his attention I've got a special treat
for you we're happy to announce the VIP
lookalike Department we all know how
difficult the creation of homunculus is
it's a fine art that takes years of
practice so when a replacement order on
VIPs comes in every detail needs to be
perfect unfortunately that's not always
the case but for the right price you too
can look like famous icons from around
the globe the image of celebrity bodies
faded from View and Peter was left
looking at the grinning demon dance
standing behind the front desk of his
impossible store once more he said there
you have it folks come on down to demon
dance discount homunculus Depot if
you're viewing the advertisement then
you've been selected for entry please
enter the nearest door for instant deals
and upgrade those old Duds for one of
our newest models what are you waiting
for come on down the logo popped up
again hovering above some bold texts
that said please enter the nearest door
Peter had had enough he switched off the
TV what a horror show he thought they
should just warn you before they put
short horror films on TV like that he
had no idea they could just slip them in
among regular commercials surely demon
Dan and his store couldn't be real right
but as his eyes drifted to the door in
his room he didn't feel quite so certain
well there was only one way to find out
Peter got up went over to the door took
a deep breath and walked through it
Peter Holland was never seen again not
as himself anyway the SCP Foundation has
long been aware of this Sinister
transmission known as SCP
5492 and luckily has found ways to
prevent it from claiming more victims
the foundation television analysis
Department as well as WebCrawler 40 y40
which is the software the foundation
uses to root out anomalous activity
online are always vigilant for signs of
demon Dan's commercial running just
observing demon Dan who is himself
classified as SCP
549a and his ads put you in immediate
danger as it can transform any nearby
doors into SCP
50491 those are interdimensional portals
that remain active for around 15 minutes
after viewing the ad so then what
specifically is SCP 15 49 it's the
entire pocket Dimension known as demon
Dan's Discount homunculus Depot a ker
class spatial anomaly constantly on the
lookout for new human victims which it
transforms into fleshy suits for its
demonic clients which let them blend in
around humans prior to its Discovery by
the foundation it's likely that demon
Dan and his associates claimed hundreds
if not thousands of lives but sadly even
discovering this anomaly came at a
gruesome cost to the foundation
on February 16th 2020 the ad played on
safe storage Warehouse 13's breakroom
television at the time of the broadcast
four Foundation Personnel were present
including security agent William Burkin
worrying that this was a potential
security threat agent Burkin
investigated the door to a nearby closet
the second he opened it he was
transformed to the storefront of demon
Dan's Discount homunculus Depot he saw
demon Dan himself standing at the corner
while four smaller reptilian imps fought
fought over a small flesh suit demon Dan
scolded them before turning his
attention to agent Burkin t t t you
aren't supposed to be here little man
how naughty I'm going to have to have a
word with marketing once I'm through
with you agent Burkin fearing for his
safety drew his weapon and shot demon
Dam three times the creature
dematerialized before appearing right
next to agent Burkin and disarming him
with a swift chop the unfortunate
security agent was then grabbed by the
consider larger demon Dan than thrown
over Dan's shoulder we know all of this
because agent Burkin standard issue
Foundation body camera recorded the
whole terrifying ordeal even as demon
Dan dragged the helpless Birkin back
into the Twisted Workshop behind the
store there Burkin saw what would soon
be his own fate right before his eyes
Dan's minions converting human bodies
into fleshy suits for their demon
clientele and this unfortunate security
officer was next Dan gave him over to a
pair of large sheeplike demons and told
them to drain skin and declaw him Burkin
video feed finally cut as the demons
pulled out the rusty tools and began to
work on him of course the SCP Foundation
wouldn't take an attack on one of their
operatives inside one of their
facilities no less lying down the
unfortunate death of William berken
allowed the foundation to refine their
methods of intercepting the broadcast of
demon Dan's commercials they even had a
new mobile Task Force Mobile Strike
Force Kappa 11 or the baffet Bashers
specifically to deal with demon Dan and
his cronies they did more than just
prevent him from taking new humans
though when the baffet Bashers teamed up
with an A-Class Clairvoyant entity to
improve their efficiency in predicting
future broadcasts they were able to
launch sting operations and arrest 21
different demonic customers for
interrogation this impressive strike
back finally gave the found Foundation
some meaningful leverage over demon Dan
and through the use of their Clairvoyant
entity they were able to call a
temporary truce and arrange a meeting
with demon Dan himself Captain Steiner
an agent of the foundation external
negotiation Department was the one to
interrogate demon Dan they sat across
from each other at a table and Demon Dan
was clearly tense frustrated with the
way the foundation had been messing with
his business all of their sting
operations were frightening off his
customers in return for letting him
continue his work the foundation wanted
Dan to turn over all the information on
his bosses and customers allowing the
foundation to track their movements when
Dan was evasive about whether he'd
comply they tried threatening him Dan
laughed them off go ahead take your best
shot little man there's a dozen more
just like me you won't stop anything
finally he was pressured into giving a
yes or no answer as to whether he'd
willingly collaborate with the
foundation and act as an informant
against his kind when demon Dan hinted
that he may be willing to comply he
began to make a horrifying gurgling
noise and gripped his head in pain he
began speaking in Latin in a voice that
wasn't his own as though the seven demon
Lords he served were speaking through
him they said you are a fool Jailer to
think a pathetic Morel such as this
could Aid you against us I have allowed
you to toil in your own delusions for
far too long you may have taken
advantage of azim modius all those years
ago but you stop nothing You Hinder
nothing you jail and barter to no avail
your time is coming and then demon Dan's
head exploded which obviously prevented
him from giving any incriminating
information on those he worked for
whoever the demon Lords are there's
certainly the secretive type you may
think that this is the end of Demon Dan
discount homunculus Depot and of SCP
5049 but soon another ad ran it
advertised the same products and
services out of the same store the only
difference was that this time a
different entity was starring in it
imagine knowing that there's a monster
right under your nose imagine knowing
that this monster is capable of killing
any human being on Earth and all because
they simply saw a photograph of its face
when this monster is on the war path
literally nothing can stop it no weapon
that human beings have invented is
capable of even slowing it down imagine
knowing in the age of mass media of
clicks and shares of 24-hour news
smartphones and Limitless social media
connecting billions across the globe
that one stray picture of this monster
leaked in the wrong Place could cause
the end of the world as we know it and
this fateful terrifying day could come
at any time congratulations you now know
how it feels to be Dr Dan the hot-headed
lead SCP Foundation researcher on the
scp096
case the anomaly itself requires no real
introduction the infamous Mass murdering
shy guy has haunted the nightmares of
foundation experts for years but nobody
is is more haunted by this thing than Dr
Dan himself for over a decade now he has
firmly believed that there's one
solution to the 096 problem termination
with extreme prejudice in his eyes to
think that 096 is ever truly contained
is an illusion they could never be sure
of how many pictures of it are out there
floating around just waiting to be seen
like a time bomb waiting to go off the
resources spent containing it and and
cleaning up after its Rampages he would
often argue would be better spent
instead figuring out how to finally kill
it but seeing as we're talking about the
SCP Foundation here not the global
occult Coalition the 05 Council didn't
see it quite the same way they
constantly overturn Dr Dan's termination
requests leaving the paranoid researcher
more furious with each rejection he
tried to warn them again and again and
again don't you see it's like a stick of
dynamite and the fuse is already lit if
you don't let me put it out before it's
too late there won't even be anyone left
to pick up the pieces but his please
fell on deaf ears until of course
incident
0961 a a Dark and Bloody day still
looked back on with shame and Horror by
even the most hardened members of
foundation staff it was the day that
scp096 gave everyone a taste of the mass
Carnage it was truly capable of Dr Dan
wasn't even there when containment was
first breached he was off on an
expedition in the snowy mountains where
096 was first found trying to discover
Clues to its true origin Dr Dan's second
in command Dr Alexi was also lucky
enough to be outside of the containment
area when the shy guy escaped according
to interviews he gave at debriefing
tribunals he was in the breakroom
treating himself to a warm cup of joe
all the other personal assigned to 0
96's containment and research were near
its containment chamber a giant cube
made of reinforced metal observing a
live feed of data being collected from
the Cub's interior as usual sensors
indicated that 096 was pacing within for
obvious reasons the foundation doesn't
maintain any kind of live visual
surveillance on
096 it wouldn't be worth the risk but
what seemed like an otherwise quiet day
suddenly took a turn for the insane the
monitors began displaying terrifying
data indicating an imminent Containment
Breach as the whales of the creature
within the cube echoed out through its
metal walls some tried to run others did
all they could to engage emergency
procedures while guards armed with heavy
Weaponry rushed into the room they all
knew in their hearts that it wouldn't
save them but what else could they do a
huge dent bulged out from the side of
the cube then another before the metal
was torn open like tissue paper as the
fury hands of the shy guy began clawing
their way through it secondary layers of
protection were deployed but they didn't
help 096 just kept ripping through all
the barriers as everyone in attendance
knew once it was in its rage State
nothing could stop it literally nothing
the guards attempted to fire on the
anomaly but their bullets did no good as
the creature burst free most of the
people in the room had at least
momentary visual contact with its face
and in Response Code Lima was declared
and the entire chamber was flooded with
a fast acting nerve gas killing everyone
everyone except for 096 itself of course
within 2 minutes 096 had broken free of
the entire containment site and began
running through the desert at Breakneck
speeds towards its distant Target the
foundation needed to act fast and find a
way to stop it before it hit a
population Center where the death toll
would Skyrock it Team Echo Romeo were
dispatched to pursue the creature in a
heavily armed attack helicopter while
MTF to one a task force specializing an
scp096 containment and Recovery forged
ahead to identify the anomaly's target
designated
096-b out of Harm's Way Dr Dan was
alerted of the disastrous situation and
offered guidance to both teams from afar
Echo Romeo's Chopper pursued 096 barely
able to keep up Dr Dan recommended
mended attempting to at least slow the
creature down with heavy arms fire even
though he knew actually stopping it
would be impossible a member of the team
used a modified xm500 antimaterial rifle
to fire several rounds at the creature
but even the shot that passed directly
through its head appeared to have no
effect on it but at least they had a
lock on its direction now 096 always
travels in a straight line directly
towards its Target smashing through any
obstacles in its way this means its
intended direction is relatively easy to
track and people in the path of its
trajectory are even easier to save but
it's a high press job reserve for MTF to
one to one passed over Echo Romeo and
096 in the series of 8 v22 ospre hoping
Beyond hope that they could outrun the
creature since there were several
different towns in its direct path but
thanks once again to the one and only Dr
Dan Echo Romeo and T one had a secret
weapon that neither team had ever
possessed before scramble scramble was
an advanced computer program created by
Dr Dan with the help of Dr Alexi which
was coded into microprocessors for
modification into camera feeds and
viewing goggles the program had been fed
intricate data concerning every single
detail of 0 96's face and as the name
suggests when encountering that visual
data in real life it scrambles it beyond
recognition in theory it would make it
far safer for operatives to be around
scp096 without activating its rage state
in theory it wasn't long before disaster
struck 096 had made its way onto I40 and
had begun attacking Vehicles it
encountered killing the people inside by
this point it had already outrun the
echo Romeo Chopper rendering them
essentially useless t one just had to
forge ahead along 0 96's trajectory and
try to get as many people out of the
danger zone as possible until 0961 was
located and destroyed by the anomaly
years of training for an awful day like
this had paid off as the first three
towns along 0 96's path were
successfully evacuated the shy guy just
ran right through all of them and no
lives were lost the same however could
not be said for Town number four as was
standard procedure to one had everyone
in the town gathered up and blindfolded
the entire team in attendance had
modified night vision goggles with
scramble microprocessors so in theory
they were better off than most from 096
if things went South the taan members
tried in vain to keep everybody in line
they were threatening to shoot anyone
who dared to remove their blindfold when
096 finally appeared it tripped during
its approach rolling and shattering
through several houses chaos erupted
some people instinctively removed their
blindfolds to see what was going on and
panicked members of taan began firing
into the crowd the screams of the
civilians and the bursts of gunfire were
all drowned out by the horrific wailing
of 096 itself as it tore through
everyone and everything to kill the
Unfortunate Souls who had seen its face
and given how many had removed their
blindfolds during the initial
pandemonium SCP 096 had a huge number of
the town's people on its list 096
located and grabbed the original
0961 the person that had first glimpsed
its face and caused all of this but in
the grand scheme of things he was just
one more body on the pile that day
though of course we mean this in a
purely metaphorical sense 096 never
leaves entire bodies the foundation
operatives in attendance were able to
figure out what had caused all this
madness and death 0
96-109 6 had had been inhabiting prior
to its initial capture and containment
but he hadn't actually seen 096 on that
fateful trip which had been taken over a
decade ago but in a photograph taken
that day of himself standing on a
picturesque Mountain Side 096 made a
cameo it took up all of four pixels a
tiny off-white dot against the snow on
the back right side of the photograph
this photograph with all the deadly
potency of an adom B mom had been
sitting there for years waiting when the
Mountaineer was looking through old
photos that morning and his eyes passed
over those few blurry pixels he didn't
have any idea that he had just laid his
eyes on one of the most dangerous
anomalies the world has ever seen but
you don't have to know only 096 does as
t one led by their Commander Major Jack
Wilford tried to retake control of the
situation things got even worse it
turned out out Dr Dan's scramble
technology the one thing that was
supposed to have given them an edge in
this situation didn't actually work as
soon as goggle wearing members of the
team laid eyes on 096 it entered its
rage State and started massacring them
it tore many of the mobile task force
members to shreds including a number of
the operatives required for piloting the
eight ospre it was a disaster of truly
epic proportions and the catastrophic
failure of Dr Dan scramble technology
was a key factor the root of the
Technology's failure was easy enough to
figure out Dr Dan's scramble
microprocessors worked fast but not fast
enough fractions of a second glimpses of
0 96's face managed to get through and
that was more than enough to set 096 off
Echo Romeo and MTF Epsilon arrived
shortly afterwards to clean up the mess
it been a disaster of such magnitude
that even a CNN reporter arrived on the
scene and started filming before being
promptly shut down by Epsilon it was a
member of echo Romeo that finally
slipped the bag over a docile 0 96's
head preparing it for containment once
again the creature now content that it
had eliminated all the Unfortunate Souls
who had seen its face he'd found 096
sitting next to a minivan that had its
roof ripped off the young family inside
being the last to have seen its face and
things were so awful in the aftermath of
the Containment Breach that the 05
Council changed their tune finally
granting Dr Dan permission to terminate
096 by any means necessary it's
terrifying to think that all this can
unfold because of a couple of poorly
timed accidents but it's probably even
more terrifying to consider that it
wasn't an accident at all it seemed
awfully convenient that both Dr Dan and
Dr Alexi were far from danger when all
hell broke loose it was also convenient
that despite the failure of his
technology being a major reason why the
breach was as deadly as it was Dr Dan
had still come out of the situation with
everything he wanted the foundation also
found this strange and the more they
looked into it the more they found
details that didn't add up aliis began
to fall apart coincidences didn't seem
so coincidental and eventually a weak
Link in the chain was identified Dr
Alexi under pressure from the foundation
Alexi spilled everything
Dr Dan had essentially orchestrated the
entire Containment Breach and on top of
that he did everything he could to make
it as deadly as possible all with the
purpose of getting the 05 Council to see
things his way and finally give him the
permission he needed to devote all of
the scp096 resources to its termination
but it came at a terrible price to Dr
Dan personally for his crimes against
the foundation and Humanity he was
permitted to try and fig figure out a
way to terminate 096 once and for all
but as payment for his crimes he himself
would also be terminated as soon as his
task was complete were the lives of all
those innocent people and Dr Dan himself
worth the price of finally being
authorized to terminate scp096 when
asked why he did all of this Dr Dan
simply said it worked there was only a
matter of time until that happened in a
major population Center and its face
spread over the world news I can kill
096 but I've killed myself in the
process while we don't agree with his
methods there's something almost
admirable about a person so
single-mindedly devoted to their cause
if you have ever taken a trip to suntop
mountain in the Mount Baker snow kwami
National Forest Washington State then
you may have come across an old wooden
structure the suntop fire lookout built
in the early 1930s the building was used
by the US Forest Service to keep watch
for any fires in the nearby Woodland at
one point suntop fire lookout would have
been M 365 days a year complete with a
bed for staff who were stationed there
on rotation the singl story Lookout
house overlooks the scenic valleys of
the White River and Huckleberry Creek
but you're not here for an informative
tourist guide you probably don't care
about the frankly fascinating history of
the lookout and how it was used as part
of the aircraft warning service during
World War II watching for enemy planes
no you're here because something much
darker lurks inside the suntop fire
lookout and even though it appears to be
a simple one-story tall wooden structure
it certainly is not short on Space SCP
3333 refers to an anomaly that the
foundation discovered inside the suntop
fire lookout house the building's
interior is a single Square Room
measuring 14 ft by 14 ft with large
windows on all four sides when standing
inside suntop fire lookout looking up at
the wooden ceiling one will immediately
notice a trap door no big deal right a
lot of places have a ceiling entrance to
a small crawl space there's probably
nothing behind that trap door apart from
a Dusty old attic there's a latch that
maybe once had a padlock there but not
anymore opening the trap door will
reveal a collapsible ladder should
anyone be brave or indeed foolish enough
to begin to climb then they'll soon find
themselves right back where they started
inside suntop fire lookout or so it will
see the thing about being in a place
like the Mount Baker snow kwami National
Forest that surrounds suntop fire
lookout is that Woodland areas are
teeming with life not just plants and
trees but birds and other animals of the
forest you can never truly be alone in a
setting like that there is there's
always life everywhere around you so
when you ascend the ladder and climb
right back into the suntop fire lookout
that is the first most noticeable
difference you will find it may take a
while at first but the nagging absence
of something unusually so abundant in a
forest will eventually become obvious
it's quiet far too quiet no bird song or
the sound of distant calls from Woodland
Critters just silence all around anyone
ascending the ladder will find
themselves in a copy of suntop fire
Lookouts interior one story higher than
the ground level of the small wooden
building with the stairs leading up to
the front door getting taller each time
to reach up to the higher and higher
building now you know the SCP Foundation
and the types of bizarre
interdimensional anomalies that they're
used to dealing with perhaps SCP 3333 is
a mirror Dimension or a plane of
existence where sound doesn't travel it
certainly seems to be identical to the
suntop fire lookout save for the lack of
any organic life outside of course it's
what you'll find living inside SCP
3333 that you may want to worry about
climbing higher up the next ladder and
through the next trapo every time with
the same result you appear at another
copy of suntop fire lookout each one
higher up than the last what first
seemed to be an innocuous unassuming
wooden building is now an endless
Ascension up into the heavens towards
the unknown in silence without a shred
of plant or animal life outside as you
climb perhaps you start to think about
how much higher these copies go this
might even be the biblical Jacob's
Ladder connecting Heaven and Earth that
would be nice wouldn't it if you were
gradually climbing your way up to
Paradise it might make it worth the trip
but ascp 3333 is nothing that Pleasant
you wouldn't be the first to attempt
this long climb when the SCP Foundation
first discovered SCP 3333 a research
detail set up an on-site base camp to
examine this spatial anomaly their first
exploration involves sending a member of
d-class personnel designated d4f 68a up
the ladder his D number is a heximal
code that when translated to text reads
o so we'll call him that for brevity's
sake during the first day's exploration
o was able to climb 184 iterations of
SCP 3333 communicating with head
researcher Dr Williams Below on the
second day o could see a pair of figures
standing motionless on a nearby Ridge
but the pair could not be seen by Dr
Williams and the other researchers at
the base camp both figures disappeared
shortly after o spotted them with the
camera he had been issued and he felt
uneasy almost certain that he saw them
point at him the next day at the 345th
copy of suntop Fire Lookout O's Behavior
started to noticeably change previously
he had been anxious about the long climb
and hadn't questioned directions given
to him by Dr Williams now he seemed to
speak more casually resisting
instructions asking Williams to climb
back down and even calling her doc
instead of doctor o also reported seeing
writing on the walls but there was no
evidence of this on his camera it
appeared that something had started to
affect him it was when o reached level
527 that things seemed to change more
dramatically rather than SCP 3333
continuing upwards the copies of suntop
fire lookout no longer had a trap door
or ladder they seemed to be arranged
side by side in a grid-like pattern
stepping out of the main doorway o
remarked on the lack of sunlight and a
walkway that connected directly to the
front door of the next iteration of SCP
3333 o complained about the lack of
natural light and again requested to be
allowed back down Dr Williams instructed
o to use the flashlights he was provided
but they wouldn't activate and their
spare batteries had vanished O then
noticed a sudden movement and just then
his microphone and camera feed went dead
almost as if someone had turned them off
it appeared that SCP 3333 had something
else lurking up there Dr Williams
oversaw the second Expedition into SCP
33 33 this time members of mobile task
force mod zero also known by the code
name characteristic egin spaces were
sent up the ladder their Ascent through
the various copies of suntop fire
lookout were not as eventful as o's with
no signs of mysterious figures or
anxious feelings that o seemed to feel
as he climbed when they reached level
527 where the copies of the lookout sto
progressing upwards and spread out in a
pattern instead their lights and
Equipment all seemed to be in working
order order however as the MTF team
split up one by one they encountered
some sort of anomaly or an effect of SCP
3333 that caused each of them to vanish
into the dark either that or something
took them these MTF units reappeared
confused and Mod Five the team's leader
Graham purcel issued an order to retreat
and the entire Squad went back down the
ladders for several days until they
finally reached the base camp again the
members of mod zero were adamant they
did not wish to climb SCP 3333 again but
Dr Williams was beginning to understand
more of the anomalies of effects it
appeared to cause abrupt changes to
people's personalities along with some
sort of phenomenon that caused things to
appear and disappear The Higher One
climb assuming these were the result of
a mimetic effect Dr Williams dispatched
a counter mic specialist for the next
Expedition this specialist was a blind
deaf and mute woman known as an net or
the null Walker who communicated via a
signaling system embedded in her hand
but was otherwise immune to any mimetic
influences observed by Dr Williams and
Graham purcel at base camp Anette made
her way to the top of SCP 3333 reporting
that she was aware of someone watching
her from outside the copies of suntop
fire lookout on her body camera a
flicker of motion occurred something
looking through the windows that ducked
out of frame when the camera passed in
its direction at the Apex of SCP 3333
Annette kept her flashlight off but
reported that she could detect blood
following it to what she assumed was a
body sounds of movement surrounded her
and as a nette switched on her
flashlight Williams and purcel saw that
it wasn't a body in front of her instead
it was a pile of rotting organs
decomposing muscles and discarded bones
and among the pile was a metal dog tag
that read MTF mod 5 G per cell the same
man who was sitting next to Dr Williams
at base camp well the same man on the
outside at least the explanation for
everything going on inside SCP
3333 all these strange occurrences and
disappearances finally came in a video
sent from Dr Williams's cell phone in it
a panicked Williams covered in blood was
fleeing from something at the top of the
recursive stack of CP
3333 there was no mimetic effect at the
apex of the suntop fire lookout copies
nothing was causing the people that the
foundation sent up to act unlike
themselves they simply weren't
themselves anymore according to her
frantic video Dr Williams had discovered
the truth about what else was hiding
within SCP
3333 with just the right amount of
vagueness and Intrigue the research team
had been drawn in it was as if they'd
been lured in by the lights of an
anglerfish realizing their Grim fate
only too late the d-class O the MTF team
even a net had been replaced an unknown
group of entities on the top level of
SCP 3333 had been carefully observing
them waiting until they would not be
seen to slip in and switch places these
entities had been creating imagined
anomalous effects like o seeing figures
that weren't really there as a way of
luring more bodies further up the stack
they wanted the foundation to keep
sending Expeditions into SCP
3333 to keep them coming back the mass
of organs musculature and bones that an
nette had stumbled across revealing the
ruse had once belonged to gram perel
before he was replaced you see the
entities residing in SCP 33333 weren't
just copying people they weren't
possessing them or mind controlling them
or even shape-shifting to steal a
person's likeness they were taking skin
these creatures hollowed out Graham o
Annette and the MTF team pulling out
their innards and crawling their way
inside filling these fleshy puppets and
leaving their internal organs to rot
these hollowed out people became vessels
for the entities of SCP 3333 to hide in
the whole thing had been a trap
intentionally exploiting human
weaknesses Intrigue and unanswered
questions you know what they say about
curiosity and these entities used it to
bring more potential vessels to the top
of SCP
3333 they pretended to be the people who
they had replaced imitating them so the
foundation would send more Personnel to
explore the tower increasing their
supply of skins Graham's dog tag had
revealed the deception and Dr Williams
had escaped up scp3 333 the members of
the research team that had already been
replaced were hot on her tail determined
to catch and Hollow her out too and by
the end of her video they had succeeded
a month later though A Team delivering
supplies realized what had happened and
the trap door was sealed Sun top fire
lookout was put under permanent guard
but at least 50 Personnel were killed or
replaced by one of the entities a new
mobile task force Lambda 1 Maxwell's
demons was created to hunt down and
neutralize any of the entities that had
escaped SCP
3333 but it's still unknown how many
left the tower and are still out there
somewhere waiting to use someone's
curiosity about the strange and unknown
against them on a cold October night in
2003 Shirley Yates of Seattle Washington
was just about to get ready for bed when
she heard a knock at the door she
approached the door and asked the person
on the other side to identify themselves
The Voice outside responded immediately
it was a Salesman who just wanted a few
moments of Mrs yates's time this was odd
for two reasons first it was almost
10:00 at night much later than is usual
for door to-door salesman and second the
knock hadn't come from Mrs yates's front
door it was coming from the door to her
bathroom has your home ever been visited
by a door-to-door Salesman if you were
born in the last 40 years then your
answer to that question is probably no
in the age of online shopping the idea
of a salesperson going from house to
house Hawking vacuum cleaners or
encyclopedia sets Feels Like A Relic
from the past it's highly unlikely you'd
ever see one walking the streets
nowadays and equally unlikely that one
would knock on your front door however
if you live in Washington state you
might need to be wary of a certain
salesman who is still doing the rounds
SCP
1879 also known as the indoor salesman
and the doorman is a phenomenon that
manifests randomly in homes throughout
Washington subjects will hear persistent
knocking from the interior doors of
their homes and the affected door
becomes classified as SCP
1879-1955 subject whose home he's just
invaded the SCP Foundation was first
alerted to the existence of the indoor
salesman when they had intercepted a 911
call coming from the home of Mrs Shirley
Yates she had opened the door to her
bathroom in an attempt to get the
salesman to stop knocking and once he
was in her home he refused to leave
according to Yates he kept disappearing
in and out of random doors in her house
foundation field agent Rogers was
equipped with a recording device and
sent in to investigate the case with
several other agents when he arrived at
the home he found Mrs Yates inconsolable
scp1
1879-s was still rapidly talking at her
and strangely enough the product he was
holding and trying to sell to her was a
border colly puppy as soon as agent
Rogers entered the room the man shifted
his attention away from Mrs Yates and
towards him he then started trying to
sell the puppy to agent Rogers agent
Rogers did not want to purchase this
puppy but he found that the man spoke so
quickly and urgently he couldn't get a
word in edgewise the man was begging
Rogers to take the puppy practically
shoving it in his face saying that he
didn't need any money and that the only
payment he needed would be some of your
time Rogers grew so annoyed at being
talked over and interrupted that he
ordered the other field agents to
apprehend the indoor salesman they did
so but as soon as the agents walked him
out of the front door of the house he
disappeared without a trace the agents
remained in the area to monitor the
situation
SCP
18792 manifested again in Mrs yates's
home 6 hours later still trying to trade
the puppy for no money just a little of
her time 12 years to be precise after
hours and hours of being worn down by
this supernaturally pushy salesman Yates
relented and agreed to take the puppy
and immediately disappeared the indoor
salesman then disappeared himself
through the closet door before he could
be apprehended again at a loss for what
to do the agents administered Class A
amnestics to Mrs yates's family and left
the reason for her disappearance wasn't
fully known until 12 years later in
2015 when she reappeared in the same
spot she disappeared from having no
concept of how much time had passed the
puppy really had just cost her 12 years
of her life stories like that of Shirley
Yates have popped up all over the state
in the years since from Everett to
walawala and everywhere in between due
to the random nature of SCP 1879 events
and the way the indoor salesman can
disappear instantly in and out of any
door in the building the SCP Foundation
has been unable to capture him the best
they've been able to do is Monitor 911
calls from across the state listening
for key words that might indicate
another SCP 1879 infestation when such
an event is reported the foundation
deploys mobile task force Row 4 AKA SHO
salesman this task Force's entire
purpose is to minimize the amount of
harm the indoor salesman is able to
cause by intercepting him before he can
make a sale this is a very important
task as evidenced by the story of Mrs
Yates since while the products the
salesman sells might be innocent he
doesn't accept payment in any normal
currency the price he asks for his
products are always bizarre and often
deadly if all someone loses is 12 years
of their life they could be considered
to be getting off EAS easy in one
instance the product being sold was a
single red rose in exchange for the
subject's heart once the deal was sealed
the subject dropped dead on the spot
with an autopsy revealing that his heart
and circulatory system vanished from
inside his body in another the indoor
salesman offered 220 bananas and told
the subject to Simply give him some
sugar the subject agreed and all candied
Goods in the home disappeared in a third
the indoor salesman was trying to sell a
thermonuclear Warhead the price of which
was the subject's soul the subject
accepted and at first nothing seemed to
have happened the foundation confiscated
the Warhead and placed it into
non-anomalous containment later that day
the subject went to listen to some music
only to find that two of her vinyl
records had gone missing Lady Soul and
Almighty Fire by world famous soul
singer artha Franklin so even though
he's incredibly invasive annoying and
his transactions can be deadly the
indoor salesman still maintains a sense
of humor the fact that the foundation
can't capture the indoor salesman means
that a lot of questions about him remain
unanswered the biggest by far is why he
does what he does in most SCP 1879
events the indoor salesman seems frantic
and desperate to make a sale often he
will refer to having quotas and
deadlines to meet which implies some
other unseen entity that he has to
answer to these questions remain
unanswered because all attempts to
interrogate the indoor salesman have
been unsuccessful when he manifests in
the location it's impossible to get him
to stray from a sales pitch and he
disappears as soon as he successfully
sells his Wares however there was one
instance where after an SCP 1879 event
took place Foundation agents were there
to witness a rare interaction between
the indoor salesman and his mysterious
employers agent Rogers and the rest of
the Sho salesmen were called out to a
home in Spokane where rapid knocking had
begun to emanate from the bedroom door
equipped with recording devices Rogers
was able to record the voice of the
indoor salesman coming from inside the
bedroom in the recording the salesman
grumbled to himself about not being able
to meet his quota by tomorrow saying
that if he didn't he'd be stuck in this
world for the next Century he started
knocking again yelling through the door
that he knew they were home he kept
knocking until he was interrupted by the
sound of a phone ringing the indoor
salesman Was Heard picking it up and
Rogers managed to record the
conversation the person calling was
apparently the indoor salesman's boss
who was calling to complain about his
performance only one side of the
conversation was heard but evidently the
indoor salesman's boss wasn't too happy
about receiving two artha Franklin
albums as payment instead of an actual
human soul the indoor salesman
apologized for the joke then told his
boss it won't happen again please don't
Hur it I'll meet the quote this time I
swear he hung up grumbling to himself
again I better get to move up to at
leise accounting this time I've paid my
dues and then some Rogers finally opened
the door to the apparent disappointment
of the indoor salesman who was hoping to
speak with the home's owner and was
quite annoyed at having another one of
his sales interrupted by MTF Row 4
Rogers tried to ask the indoor salesman
who he'd just been speaking to on the
phone but as usual the salesman started
talking over him now see here let's
think logically he said you know I'm not
going to tell you anything I know you're
not likely to buy what I'm selling so
let's just move on to Green of pastures
I'm coming up close to a deadline and
I'm sure you're swamped with making sure
good people don't lose their job so I'll
just be on my way and let you do that
ciao the indoor salesman tried to close
the door but agent Rogers blocked it
with his arm he was tired of this SCP
giving him the runaround and he was
going to keep the indoor salesman here
if it was the last thing he did he
demanded The Entity stay and be
interviewed and other members of the
town task force apprehended the salesman
making sure he couldn't leave the room
the indoor salesman now held in place by
several armed men seemed to finally
relent he told Rogers I'm busy so I'll
tell you what I'm going to give you
something no money out of your pocket
and we'll call it even sound good Rogers
just wanting to get this whole thing
over with agreed to those terms 3
seconds later every agent on the scene
was dead and the indoor salesman was
able to straighten his tie pick up his
briefcase and walk through the door to
the the bathroom when the bodies of
agent Rogers and the rest of the MTF Row
4 were examined by Foundation scientists
the cause of death was found to be in
every case thousands of coins suddenly
appearing in not only their pockets but
also inside their stomachs lungs and
even under their skin later that day the
indoor salesman was reported at a home
in the same neighborhood he was seen
trying to sell The house's owner
80-year-old retiree Alan Johnson a Glock
18 pistol in exchange for his attention
as he had done so many times before the
indoor salesman disappeared through
another door before the foundation was
able to reach the scene and when the SCP
arrived they found Mr Johnson still
alive but now missing his prefrontal
cortex the part of the brain that
controls attention it's likely that
because of the nature of the entity SCP
1879 might be entirely impossible to
contain the foundation might never find
out any anything more than what they
already know about the indoor salesman
the way he's able to manifest behind
closed doors or the reason he has to
keep filling quotas for an unseen boss
who apparently doesn't have a very good
sense of humor so if you're ever in
Washington state be careful who you open
your doors to especially if the knocking
you hear is coming from inside your
house a d-class drag races through the
testing Zone screaming at the top of his
lungs and doing Donuts a mime who is
also in the testing chamber stares with
disapproval tapping his foot impatiently
did we mention that the cars made of
spiders yeah this one is going to be a
weird one folks stay tuned for one of
the craziest SCP stories you've ever
heard Emily had always dreamed of taking
a trip to Paris when the opportunity
actually came to visit the city she was
overjoyed she spent her time exploring
art museums tasting the bread and cheese
and walking through the city streets
taking in the sights one of her favorite
things about Paris was all the street
performers as she walked nibbling on a
panel chakola she delighted in the
antics of jugglers tossing colorful
balls into the air she gasped at the
feet of athleticism and Grace
demonstrated by acrobats and
contortionists she giggled at the Absurd
shows put on by puppeteers and dab tears
from her eyes at the sound of beautiful
songs played and sung by musicians it
became part of her daily routine one
night as Emily was walking back to her
hostel after a long languid dinner she
found herself walking down a street she
had not encountered before there was no
one around except for her it was a
lovely moment of Peace but it also
struck her as a little bit eerie and she
wished for The Familiar throngs of
people up ahead she spotted the
silhouette of another person and let out
a sigh of relief as she got closer she
could make out the black and white
striped shirt the suspenders the Black
Beret
the white face makeup ruged cheeks and
red lips a mime a real classic French
mime she couldn't believe her luck when
he spotted Emily approaching the MIM
began to start a performance he began
with a classic the invisible box he felt
around the walls of the invisible box
looking out with exaggerated wide eyes
and an open mouth Emily clapped and
reached into her bag for a little bit of
money she could use to tip him after all
he was putting on a perform performance
just for her he deserved it she walked
closer to the mime looking for a place
to put her tip she didn't see one so she
held up her hand offering the money
directly to the mime as he took notice
of how close she was getting the mime
began shaking his head vigorously eyes
wide and insistent she didn't understand
that he was trying to warn her until it
was too late dozens and dozens of
spiders began to crawl over the mim's
face out from inside of his clothes from
his shoes pouring out over the street
and crawling up onto Emily she tried to
brush them off she tried to run away but
no matter how hard she tried the spiders
just kept coming all she could do was
scream in an attempt to experience a
little bit of live performance Emily
unwittingly came across SCP
3247 SCP 3247 is a humanoid entity
standing at approximately 1.7 m in
height it wears a striped shirt and
suspenders similar to the Garb of a
stereotypical French mime as well as
what appears to be white makeup on its
face and all other Exposed Skin though
these aspects of its appearance seem as
if they should be removable the clothing
and makeup are in fact parts of the
entity's physiology and cannot be
removed from its body this is not the
only unusual aspect of the entity's
physical form though it looks corporeal
and solid The Entity cannot touch or
directly interact with any solid matter
with one particular exception there is a
colony of spiders living on and inside
of SC CP
3247 these spiders have officially been
designated as CP
3247 and are highly protective of SCP
3247 if anyone or anything attempts to
approach SCP 3247 in a threatening
manner the spiders will swarm the
Potential Threat as any Savvy anomalous
activity enthus might have already
gathered these are of course no ordinary
spiders not only do they dwell on and in
an intangible mime but they have a
peculiar response to witnessing a human
being making specific gestures or
pantomiming activities when this occurs
the colony of spiders will form the
shape of an object related to the
gestures which they will then hold for
up to three hours or until given
additional stimuli that prompt a change
in shape while the spider call is
assembled into shape they will be able
to share some of the given objects
functions in spite of being technically
nothing more than a mass of
well-coordinated
arachnids as for a SCP
3247 it is either incapable of speech or
unwilling to speak instead it
communicates with Foundation staff via
silent miming when it does the spiders
will frequently react to its gestures
becoming effectively living props SCP
3247 does not seem to be especially
thrilled with this likely because miming
is inherently a propess art form and
these spider based props undermine its
artistic Vision otherwise though the
presence of the spiders does not seem to
bother SCP
3247 in order to better understand the
nature of s SCP
3247 Foundation staff conducted a series
of tests in each test a d-class was
given a gesture to perform in the
presence of SCP
3247 then the research staff would
record the SP colony's response during
the first test the research staff
ordered D 11424 to attempt to get as
close to SCP 3247 as possible they did
not of course warn him about the spiders
he entered the testing chamber and
approached the mime who was pantomiming
the act of climbing stairs as the MIM
pretended to ascend an invisible
staircase and D1 11424 grew closer
instances of SCP
3247 emerged to take the shape of a
staircase much to the mim's frustration
SCP 3247 stopped its performance
throwing up its hands in a gesture of
defeat the spiders turned their
attention to D1 11424 and began to swarm
him treating him as a Potential Threat
panicking and Unsure how to communicate
with SCP 3247 while the spiders were
overpowering him D 11424 began to wave
frantically at the mime the mime simply
Shrugged giving him a look that said
well what do you want me to do about it
at this point control intervened
instructing D1 11424 to pantomime some
kind of activity fortunately before
turning to a life of crime D1 11424 had
spent several years in a professional
improv troop and was well acquainted
with pantomime his performing instincts
kicked in and he leapt into action he
put a hand to his ear as if listening to
the ringing of a telephone the spiders
stopped their attack responding
immediately to his queue they formed
into the shape of a small table with an
old fashioned rotary phone on top the
mime rolled its eyes in disdain at the
sight of this prop based performance but
d11 424 was on a roll he crossed to the
phone picked up the receiver and held it
to his ear hello he asked out of habit
he wasn't expecting to hear a voice on
the other line but then he did or rather
he heard the approximation of a human
voice created by a swarm of anomalous
spiders it sounded a bit like a human
voice sped up high-pitched and squeaky
speaking some sort of gibberish
realizing that this was his moment to
escape d142 placed the phone back in
place and promptly left the testing
chamber the spiders remained in the
shape of the rotary phone and the table
for the next 2 hours at which point they
disassembled and returned to their home
on a SCP
3247 after his surprisingly creative
work in this first test it was decided
that d11 424 would be the designated
test subject for all future testing with
SCP
3247 provided that additional
complications did not arise though he
wasn't especially fond of spiders d11
424 was more than happy to accept the
assignment not that he had much choice
in the matter still it was definitely a
better deal than getting fed to SCP 682
and it was a nice excuse to use his
improv skills again after a long
retirement during the second test d144
knew what to expect from SCP
3247 for this test he was told to
pantomim playing tug of-war with an
invisible opponent and an invisible rope
now that he knew his improvisational
scene partner would be a colony of
spiders he was able to enter the testing
chamber with confidence once inside he
began to pantomime pulling on a rope
having that rope tugged away from him by
a strong opponent and struggling to pull
back the spiders reacted right away
arranging themselves into the shapes of
a long rope one side of which was in D1
11424 hands as well as a large humanoid
vaguely muscular in shape that was
holding the other side of the Rope the
spiders gave the Rope a sharp tug
causing D1 11424 to lose his balance and
fall over the Rope slipping out of his
grasp aside from some injury to his
pride he was otherwise unharmed during
test number three d11 424 was instructed
to enter the testing chamber and close
his fist while extending the thumb and
index finger in a gesture colloquially
known as finger guns sure enough as soon
as he assumed this position the spiders
assembled in to the shape of a handgun
d11 424 was then instructed to pick up
the spider gun and squeeze the place
where the trigger would be if it was a
real gun and not you know spiders a loud
cracking sound was heard when the
d-class squeezed as a spider shot out of
the barrel of the gun at high speed
before smacking into the nearby wall
leaving a small hole in the surface d11
424 fired several more times each Shot
firing an individual spider at a pace
that attending researchers described as
faster than a speeding bullet after
firing six rounds of spiders at the wall
d11 424 was instructed to place the
spider gun back on the ground during
test number 76 d11 424 was ordered to
hold his hands together and wiggle four
fingers on each hand effectively
pantomiming a spider the research team
was curious to see what the spiders
would do when presented with a shape
that match their usual unassembled form
SCP 3247 who generally did not react
much to the experiments on its spiders
began shaking its head in mild
disappointment as approximately 640
spiders emerg from its body dividing
themselves into groups of eight each
group of eight spiders then joined to
form one large spider leaving eight
spiders these eight then split into
pairs who joined together into one
larger spider and so on and so forth
until there was one single giant spider
made from the hundreds of smaller
spiders at this point d11 424 followed
his heart jumping on to the mega
spider's back and riding it like a bull
at the rodeo as the spider bucked and
ran back and forth across the room
according to official transcripts D1
11424 yelled Yeehaw throughout this part
of the test until the head researcher
ordered him to climb down from the
spider and exit the room he was
reprimanded for his behavior and warned
that if he acted without approval again
he would be taken off the project and
reassigned to a much less enjoyable
position as one of the designated eyes
on SCP 173 d11 424 immediately agreed to
comply with future instructions during
test number 133 d11 424 was sent into
the testing chamber and told to Shadow
boox he danced back and forth across the
cell doing his best Sylvester Stone
impression and throwing punches in the
general direction of the spiders in
response approximately 3,000 spiders
poured out of SCP
3247 assembling into the shadowy shape
of a b boxer and began to attack d11 424
the mass of spiders conducted itself at
the level of a professional boxer
dodging d142 Force hits before coming
back at him with a jab cross lead
uppercut and rear uppercut before he
could defend himself d11 424 fell to the
ground unconscious and guards were
forced to interrupt the test in order to
remove him from the room and take him to
the infirmary for medical treatment
after taking some time to recuperate
d142 turned to testing with SCP
3247 he was instructed to mine steering
a wheel such as that of a car
immediately a number of spiders
previously unseen during testing emerged
from SCP
3247 arranging themselves into the shape
of a sedan d11 424 was then commanded to
climb inside of the spider car and see
if he could start it he refused
insisting I'm not getting in a spider
car are you nuts when pressed by control
to comply with orders he made a rude
hand gesture I'll let you guess what
that was the spiders began to scramble
to reassemble themselves in response to
the changed gesture prompting control to
stop the test early to spare the
researchers sensibilities with strict
guidelines to avoid inappropriate or
violent gestures d11 424 was sent back
into the testing chamber with
instruction to try out a variety of
animal inspired gestures in Rapid
succession he formed one hand into a
fist and made a peace sign with the
other hand putting them together to make
a snail as as he made his hand snail
crawl through the air the spiders
crawled onto the floor and assembled
into the shape of a snail in front of
d11 424 though the spiders moved quickly
at their usual scuttling Pace once they
formed into the snail they slowed to a
gradual creep d424 noted a shiny slimy
Trail left behind on the floor as the
spider snail moved he was asked to
consider touching it but refused simply
stating ew no next he took his hands and
formed the shape of a wolf's head
howling at the moon the research staff
were curious to see if the spiders would
form a wolf's head or the animal's
entire body they got their answer as the
spider swarmed and shifted forming the
shape of a full-sized gray wolf the wolf
padded back and forth across the room
before sitting down lifting its head and
emitting an audible howl that sounded
almost indistinguishable from the real
thing next D 11424 crossed his thumbs
over each other fluttering hands like a
pair of wings the spider separ ated into
smaller groups and came together to form
butterflies similar in size to a monarch
these spider butterflies began to Flat
their wings and much to d11 424 surprise
they took flight and swirled through the
air around him the d-class was so moved
by the beautiful sight that he shed a
single tear which he promptly wiped away
out of embarrassment control then
prompted him to try the next animal
gesture D1 11424 used his hands to form
the shape of a rabbit several of the
spiders crawled the way returning to SCP
3247 and the remaining spiders took on
the form of a rabbit the spider rabbit
hopped realistically around the room
twitching its ears and tail at this
point D1 11424 was instructed to offer
the spider rabbit a carrot he produced a
carrot from his pocket holding it out in
front of him the spider rabbit hopped
over to him and one Crunch at a time
began to eat the carrot until none
remained d11 424 appeared shaken up and
asked to leave the testing chamber as he
followed all of his instructions this
request was granted when he exited the
chamber all he would say was where the
hell did the carrot go it doesn't have a
stomach it doesn't have a mouth where
did it go SCP 3247 is kept in an
isolated chamber located in the arachnid
wing of area 12 it does not appear to
require food or rest but it has been
provided with a television and a
collection of silent films for morale
purposes instances of SCP 3247 are fed
via a full fully automated system that
dispenses 20 G of live crickets every
week should a Containment Breach occur
staff have been instructed to find a way
to make escaped spiders take on the
shape that renders them motionless then
simply pick the spider cluster up and
place it back inside of the cell it is
unlikely that the foundation will ever
get an explanation for where the
intangible mime and his merry band of
spider performers originated from but
one thing is clear they won't be
performing in public again anytime soon
somehow most likely through some
nefarious means a fateful postcard has
been sent to one of the residents of the
murky Mysterious aranam Island living on
this particular Island was already a
strange and scary enough existence given
the horrors the inhabitants of anaram
share their home with but perhaps the
only thing just as horrible as life on
that island was being sent a postcard
sure that does doesn't sound all that
horrible postcards are usually used to
show a corner of the world far away and
extend well wishes from friends or
relatives on vacations but ordinarily
postcards don't depict a photo of scp096
with the words wish he was there
scrawled on the other side from its
containment cell at the SCP Foundation
the shy guy instantly sensed that
somebody somewhere had seen a picture of
its face breaking down into an enraged
fit of homicidal insecurity scp096
immediately broke from its containment
chamber and made a CrossCountry beine
heading straight for arinum at
anomalously accelerated speeds little
did the creature or the foundation know
that the shy guy was being led straight
into a trap and the poor island resident
who had receive the chilling postcard
while they were unlucky enough to be the
bait while the s CP Foundation started
frantically trying to track down where
it had gone the shy guy had already made
its way to a wooden cabin belonging to
the unfortunate postcard recipient
emerging from the now emptied home once
the owner was no more scp096 would have
returned to his cell just as quickly as
he left that is if he wasn't the only
monstrous creature on the island a loud
and sudden noise caught the creature's
attention the sound of an old steam
train whistle it rang out once more from
somewhere off in the distance but there
was so much thick fog hanging in the air
around arinum that it was almost
impossible to see anything especially
with how dark it was the second time the
whistle sounded it was closer but there
was another sound too and not the loud
chugging of a steam engine that you
would expect it was an erratic heavy
thuing the noise of lots of something
drumming against the ground causing the
Earth itself to shutter legs they were
the steps of multiple huge legs crawling
across the surface of the island heading
straight towards scp096 a third piercing
whistle rang out even closer still this
time the orange glow of a light could be
seen dulled by the surrounding fog but
getting brighter and clearer as it came
closer the light was casting Shadows
against the dark fog long long spinley
shapes of spidery appendages until
before the Shy Guy's eyes a creature of
pure nightmares came bursting out of the
fog it was a monstrous sight even to
scp096 its body was the Red Front engine
of an old-fashioned steam train hoisted
off the ground by four pairs of enormous
black spinley spider-like legs that
propelled the Beast forwards at a
terrifying speed able to move without
the limitation ations of needing to
follow a railroad track the monster was
barreling towards scp096 with a twisted
smile on its grotesque face at the front
of the locomotive was its circular face
with its unnaturally white eyes and a
mouth that sported rows of razor sharp
teeth all covered in blood this hellish
Abomination a being that was part steam
engine and part giant spider was the
terror of arinum himself the carnivorous
Cho chw Charles seeing Charles racing
towards them on its eight spider legs
would be enough to make anyone freeze up
and stop in their tracks out of sheer
Terror and scp096 was compelled to do
the same except the terrifying train
creature's pale eyes were looking
directly at the shy guy as Charles sized
the anomaly up as its next meal he was
looking at it and that meant scp096 had
to kill him the question was how could
it how could the skinny spindly humanoid
hope to even fight something like Choo
Charles he was much bigger even more
fearsome but as quick as Charles could
move on his spidery legs he was not
faster than scp096 in the blink of an
eye the shy guy raced off shrieking and
sobbing in despair leaving Charles to
continue roaming his island territory in
search of other human inhabitants to
terrorize
scp096 had retreated to some nearby
Woods quick enough to move out of
Charles's path somewhere it could hide
for now but the shy guy could feel a
familiar painful feeling almost pulling
him back towards Cho Chu Charles right
back into Harm's Way scp096 possessed an
inescapable compulsion to kill anyone
who looked at its face and that seemed
to include horrifying part train part
spider hybrids it was a fact of the shy
guys's very existence he had to go after
whoever looked at him and make them pay
in fact it took all the creature's Own
Strength not to instantly rush back over
to Charles to try scp096 knew that if it
did then there was little chance it
would survive coming face to train face
with the terror of arinir however while
it was watching chooo Charles from a
safe distance seeing him crawl across
the landscape on his multiple legs that
as scp096
noticed something it was another light
obscured by the fog but this one was
much higher up one could almost mistake
it for the moon if it wasn't getting
closer all the while accompanied by the
sound of woring rotors well the shy guy
had been evading Cho Chu Charles the SCP
Foundation had been tirelessly trying to
track down its location and now they'd
found their runaway anomaly here on
aranam island as the chopper carrying
the mobile task force Drew nearer the
tyrannical train turned and took notice
to scp096 the foundation's arrival could
have meant a way home and away from the
spidery steam engine but to Charles the
approaching chopper meant only one thing
a new source of food Captain one of the
MTF troops aboard the chopper called
over his headset what is it do we have
eyes on scp096 the captain replied
before realizing what he'd said well not
eyes on because then it would have
jumped up onto the chopper and killed us
all I mean is there any sign of scp096
on the island negative although you
should probably see this the soldier
replied begrudgingly the captain
unbuckled himself from his seat and
snatched the foundation operatives
binoculars using them to look down at
arinum below it didn't take him long to
spot the massive multi-legged
monstrosity that was cho cho Charles who
had fallen still waiting for the chopper
to descend low enough for him to reach
good cravy what on Earth is that thing
the captain exclaimed before taking
another look through the binoculars is
that wait what is an instance of SCP
2086 doing out here SCP 2086 was an
Infamous anomalous species the
foundation had encountered before much
like Charles they were anthropod likee
creatures with multiple long legs that
protruded from a body resembling a
man-made mode of Transport however SCP
2086 is usually took on the appearance
of buses while in vehicle form sir I I
don't think that's an SCP 2086 the
lookout replied to me it looks more like
an instance of SCP
3023 impossible all the way out here the
captain retorted we're nowhere near the
region where the anomaly occurs that
could have screed its way from Germany
and take a nest here sir the trooper
responded yet another anomaly that
Chucho Chu Charles bore a striking
resemblance to SCP 3023 was a rare
phenomenon that was known to occur at
random but was limited to a specific
area of central Germany the effect of
this phenomenon caused ordinary everyday
inanimate objects of any shape or size
to suddenly turn into aggressive spiders
sporting eight legs That Grew From
whatever was affected by SCP
3023 perhaps Chuchu Charles was indeed
an instance of SCP 3023 or some distant
evolutionary offshoot of SCP 2086 who
was hard to say for sure the only thing
for sure was that Charles was a
man-eating Beast more so than an
Insidious villain and being so highly
territorial he considered the entire
island of Aaron neum to be his natural
habitat and his hunting ground anything
that arrived in his vicinity was prey to
the terrifying train and his ravenous
craving for human flesh meant he was
ready to attack the descending SCP
Foundation Chopper all right let's go go
go the MTF Captain called to his troops
signaling them to start repelling out of
the helicopter and down to the island
keep your scramble goggles on Max we
still need a recapture 096 but first
priority is taking down this big ugly
beast wearing goggles specifically
designed to distort the shy guy from
their view the team began ABS selling
out of the aircraft but Chucho Chu
Charles was already waiting for them
rearing back on its four back legs the
nightmares train spider swiped at the
descending MTF operatives but first
seemed like an instinctive uncoordinated
assault quickly became precise and
Relentless strikes as Charles sliced
through some of the cables the MTF
troops were using to repel down their
Lifeline cut the Unlucky Foundation
operatives plummet from midair right
down towards where the terror of Aon
niram was waiting for them to fall a few
of the mtfs made it to the ground alive
and immediately began retaliating
against Chuchu Charles the gunfire from
their weapons flickered all around the
carnivorous creature but their bullets
could barely chip the red paintwork on
his steam train body dashing towards his
helpless human prey on his many legs
Charles began to Feast then suddenly
something started pulling at one of his
huge spider legs pulling Charles back
moments before he had a chance to claim
his latest victim the captain of the
foundation's MTF it was scp096 having
zipped out of hiding and shrieking
wildly as it used all of its strength to
wrench one of choo Charles's multiple
limbs angered that it couldn't reach the
MTF Captain the part spider part train
hybrid stomped the leg that was being
pulled in a successful attempt to free
itself from the shy guys's grip but in
the same instant scp096 used its anomaly
speed to reappear in front of the
already angered locomotive monster with
his railroad rage about to reach its
Breaking Point Charles entered into a
Relentless Rampage making quick work of
the leftover MTF troops before setting
his sight squarely on scp096 but doing
that was his biggest mistake now Choo
Chu Charles had seen the shy guy twice
and to the insecure anomaly that meant
Charles had to go traveling faster than
even the multi-legged monstrosity could
perceive scp096 began racing towards Cho
Chu Charles's many legs the shy guy had
realized that it didn't stand a chance
of dealing with the terror of arinum the
same way it handled all the others that
had seen its face so instead it had
settled on a new approach specifically
tailored to taking down the spider-
legged steam engine one by one scp096
started knocking Charles's many legs out
from underneath him effectively tripping
him up over over and over again the shy
guy moved so quick that the cumbersome
Charles could barely react in time
having one leg after the other knocked
out from beneath him causing him to
Tumble to the ground normally chooo
Charles was smart enough to retreat if
he encountered something that could
fight back if he was injured badly
enough the spider-like creature would
Scuttle out of Harm's Way in order to
heal his wounds but the rage at being
constantly tripped up by scp096 was
distracting Charles from the Shy Guy's
true ploy with every leg it knocked out
from underneath the spidery steam train
scp096 had been gradually directing
Charles towards a nearby Gorge with a
terrifying burst of anomalous speed the
shy guy caused Cho Chu Charles to topple
over sideways rolling over himself until
he landed upside down in the bottom of
the Rocky Gorge the multi-legged
locomotive monster spindly legs flailed
desperately as he tried to reposition
himself but with no luck scp096 had
managed what first SE seemed to be
impossible and beaten the terror of Aon
niram Cho Chu Charles or for now at
least you all know exactly who I am the
bald chemistry teacher looked around at
the men surrounding him in the desert
Cadillacs leather jackets blacked out
Shades the gang members shifted
nervously from foot to foot as the man
bragged openly about what he's done to
build his criminal Empire Walter White's
attention turned back to the man in
front of him a slight sneer played
around his lips now say my name the man
took a moment to reply as the desert
wind blew behind him he seemed to be
weighing his options realizing quickly
that he had lost all control over the
situation you're you're Heisenberg
you're G bang Walter White fell to the
ground dead the characters all around
yeled in Surprise Drew their guns and
started wildly pointing them around the
circle trying to figure out who killed
the Great Heisenberg but his killer just
stared in awe from his couch in the
front room as the Netflix show kept
playing on the TV had the toy gun in his
hand really done that Josh had admitted
to himself that he had a problem a long
time ago but at least being a yard sale
addict was cheaper than just a regular
old retail addict actually in truth he
was also an estate sale addict a garage
sale addict and a thrift store addict
anywhere you could buy people's old junk
for rock bottom prices is he would sniff
it out the Saturday that his life
changed forever was just like any other
Saturday really in the sweaty heat of
the Atlantic City suburbs he hadn't
meant to stop by any sales today but one
just so happened to catch his eye there
was a box marked nerd stuff and he took
that as a personal challenge was this
some old lady's version of nerd stuff or
a veteran dungeon Master's Treasure
Trove the reality was somewhere in
between the two there were a couple of
seasons of Buffy on VH chess a copy of
the original deos X and some Legend of
Zelda plushies it hadn't really been
worth stopping his car for except for a
little plastic splash of color that
caught his eye Josh reached way down to
the bottom of the box and rooted around
for it there was no way it couldn't
possibly be the toy he'd spent all his
childhood asking for and never getting
but in fact it was a 1985 Nintendo
Entertainment System zapper with an
orange grip and Barrel NES gray body
work and the Beautiful font printed
along the side it was unmistakable he
threw a wad of cash at the old lady
behind the table and rush back into his
car quickly as he could it was time to
cancel his Day plans he had a childhood
dream to fulfill but no sooner that he
had got home and flipped on his TV the
dream Came Crashing Down around him his
old NES the one he'd had since he was a
little kid had sadly keeled over it
refused to power on no matter what he
did so that made his zapper pretty much
useless the best he could do with it now
would be to point it at the TV and make
pew pew noises with his mouth so Josh
opened up Netflix and put on an episode
of Breaking Bad little did he know as he
raised the zapper to the screen that he
was actually in possession of SCP
674 nobody would know looking at it on
the surface even the most hardcore
Gamers wouldn't have a clue because you
can fully disassemble clean and
reassemble the zapper and get no
indication that it's anything other than
what it appears to be however as soon as
the gun is pointed at a television
screen or a computer monitor of any kind
it starts to pose a very real threat or
at least a very real fictional threat if
you shoot at the screen whatever media
is playing on it at the time will react
and adapt to what is just happened that
means characters on the screens will
react in accordance with the rules of
their respective univers versus in a
grounded realistic drama The Gunshot
will behave like any other killing or
wounding the victim with perhaps enough
time for them to give a dying monologue
but in an episode of Rick and Morty the
shock could manifest in any number of
bizarre and creative ways news crews
that witnessed the user shooting a
person in their live report will
continue to cover the incident as if it
is part of the ongoing story if you
shoot Walter White he falls to the
ground dead Josh stared at the screen
and utter amazement he didn't expect the
writers to kill off their main character
just like that wasn't there supposed to
be another Nine episodes what would they
do to fill all that time as the episode
played out it seemed to mostly just
follow Jesse trying desperately to
escape with his money before it was too
late he kept glancing towards the camera
for some reason with a slight look of
fear in his eyes very strange creative
decision there Josh backed out of the
show to scroll through his continue
watching there was something a little
creepy about how he'd point the zapper
at the TV pulled the trigger and
perfectly at that moment a character had
been shot time to pick out another show
without any guns and murder for a bit
you know something safe The Familiar
meloda tune filled the lounge as various
shots of Dunder Mifflin employees busied
themselves shredding credit cards and
answering phone calls it never ceased to
make his worries go away seeing the
words the office appear on the screen he
settled into the couch watching as the
characters all gathered in the
conference room room for some first aid
training the CPR dummy lay on the floor
with Michael Scott earnestly explaining
to the woman that the victim appeared to
have lost their limbs he laughed along
as the scene descended into chaos as
none of the employees took the training
seriously at all even though he'd seen
this episode countless times it never
got old absent-mindedly he pointed the
gun at the TV and pulled the trigger
bang Pam collapsed on the ground all of
the characters Dove out of the way
trying to find cover behind behind their
chairs not daring to peek out at the
camera only the first aid lady stayed on
the scene trying her best to resuscitate
Pam it cut to a shot of Dwight talking
to the camera sadly he said that it was
almost funny but there was a real
heaviness in the moment his eyes were
red like he'd been crying off camera
Josh flipped the TV off and stared at
himself in the dark reflection was he
dreaming he hadn't just done that had he
fortunately for Josh and for the rest of
humanity he had not killed Jenna friser
or Brian Cranston he hadn't even killed
their characters in the shows at least
not for anyone other than himself
Research into SCP 674 shows that the
appearance of characters being killed
off on screen only exists in the mind of
the shooter for everyone else the office
Remains the Same as it always was
unfortunately for Josh however Pam is
now dead in that universe and will
always be whenever he watches an episode
it leaves a real Shadow over the later
Seasons but the characters appar ly
managed to do a good job pivoting into
its new darker tone other shows that
have been tested in research conditions
have yielded interesting results like in
Star Trek it is impossible to actually
kill Captain Kirk instead various red
shirts always just so happen to dive in
front of him or fall into frame at the
pivotal moment with a small Dead Zone on
the right hand side of the screen
characters who witness enough shootings
have the sense to stick to that side of
the frame whenever the shot is on them
sometimes going so far as to plead
directly with the viewer breaking the
fourth wall in their desperation to
survive when Josh came back from a long
walk outside he'd convinced himself that
what he had seen earlier was all just
some vivid dream a dream he didn't
remember waking up from but definitely
wasn't happening anymore he'd play some
video games that's what he would do he
had decided he would just play some
Super Smash Bros and unwind anyone who
has ever said that sentence to
themselves will know firsthand how
foolish that is not 10 minutes later
Josh had definitely forgotten all about
his dream from before he was too busy
raging and cursing at the screen he
couldn't stand playing against King
dididi that stupid Hammer move always
got him without thinking Josh snatched
the zapper from the couch next to him
and blasted Didi right in the face in
classic Smash Bros style the giant
penguin King was launched backwards
flying off the screen in a blast of
colorful smoke but he didn't respond for
a second his character just stood on the
screen awkwardly before it kicked him
back out to the character select screen
this time though King Didi's picture was
missing Josh couldn't help himself he
set up a free-for-all match straight
away picking all the characters he hated
to fight against Sonic Mario Pikachu
Bowser link NES even we fit trainer one
after the other bang bang bang he felt a
strange sense of satisfaction once he'd
done his work great now the character
list only had the fair balanced ones
left they just so happened to all be his
favorite characters too but why stop
there Josh jumped across to Elden ring
and marched his night up through the
gate to Stormville Castle before marget
even had gotten through his opening cut
scene Josh had shot the boss right in
the face this boss battle that he'd been
stuck on for hours was over before it
even started what could he do now he put
on an episode of stranger things and
shot the demogorgan then MF Gideon in
the Mandalorian
and some goblins in Hogwarts Legacy the
clickers from The Last of Us took a
couple extra shots but went down easy
enough he went over to his PC and killed
the Ender Dragon in Minecraft without
blowing up any beds he won a game of
Rocket League 530 after he shot both
cars on the opposing team he played
through doors in Roblox without a single
jump scare he would just shoot any
monster that filled his screen what
could be better he reckoned it was time
for more movies walking back across the
lounge spinning the gun around his
finger like a western he wondered if now
would be a good chance to hunt down all
the legendary animals in Red Dead 2 it
would certainly make the job a lot
easier if he could kill them all in just
one shot he just need to be careful not
to shoot Arthur by accident but then
Josh sat on the remote the TV flicked
over to an old rerun of Bob Ross just
that he'd been squaring up to shoot he
pulled the trigger before he could react
the canvas was splattered red from
somewhere off camera he heard the
artist's wheezing voice try to comfort
him there are no mistakes
just happy but he died before he could
say another word the exposition gun
first came onto the SCP foundation's
radar when a strange police report was
doing the rounds on an email chain
amongst local authorities they were all
finding a great deal of value from a man
called Josh who had turned himself in at
his local station in Atlantic City for
quote killing like everyone naturally
the police took his report very
seriously for all of about 10 minutes as
soon as they realized he was talking
about video games TV and movie
characters the whole case turned into
one big joke they sat Josh down in front
of a TV and played him episodes of the
shows he was talking about pointing out
characters still alive in scenes after
he'd supposedly shot them to death but
he seemed to just grow more distressed
as he realized he was experiencing this
phenomenon Alone by the time Foundation
agents tracked Josh down and took him in
for questioning the gun had moved on he
marched it straight back to the old lady
who' sold it to him who had then sold it
on again Josh's full account of events
and description of the zapper were taken
before he was administered Class C
amnestics and allowed to continue with
his yard sale addiction uninhibited SCP
674 was found sometime later in the
possession of a 33-year-old ccasian male
simply referred to as Mr S A reclusive
man in the neighboring City Mr s first
gained the SCP foundation's attention
through his extremist political blog in
which he claimed to have assassinated
prominent political figures news anchors
and talk show hosts while the truth of
those claims was demonstrably false it
was clear from the way he described
events that he really did believe the
delusion after being questioned it was
discovered that he had never left his
home instead he stayed on his couch
watching news reports and firing at any
prominent figures that appeared
believing that he was indeed killing
them in the real world despite claiming
that he was using SCP 674 to prevent a
military police state using the device
to assassinate so many high-profile
figures had the opposite effect on his
video reality in his blog posts he
described an increasingly unstable
Global Order martial law and
catastrophic events consistent with the
hypothetical release of two deadly scps
his house was barricaded with security
cameras set up in every direction the
more he had been using the gun the more
the characters and journalists saw on TV
had threatened him claiming that the SCP
Foundation were on their way to
apprehend him and that he would face
retribution for what he had been doing
Mr s's intended ambush of foundation
agents failed while they appeared to be
dying on the security feeds he had set
up the agents experienced no physical
harm in reality as they apprehended the
man and seized SCP 674 while the
majority of researchers have deemed that
SCP 674 is harmless to all but the
mental well-being of the shooter there
was a notably Sinister result to Mr s's
time in Foundation detention alone in
his cell Mr s soon started to engage in
heated arguments with the security
camera set up to monitor him there is no
record of any voices in the room other
than his own yet he seemed to be locked
in a fierce argument all of a sudden Mr
s dropped to the ground Dead with three
38 caliber handgun bullets lodged in his
chest the entirety of his holding cell
was searched for evidence of a shooter
but none was found the exposition gun
remains in a locked plastic case in
storage site 23 aside from regular
cleaning and maintenance it is used
under controlled circumstances to
creatively gather intelligence about
further SCP activity in the event of the
site being compromised Personnel are
allowed to destroy the exposition gun at
their own discretion should it fall into
the wrong hands good grief said Jo yro
Kujo as he his grandfather Joseph joar
and the rest of their Allied group of
Stan users hid from the light of day in
the shadows of a ruined building outside
amorphous semi humanoid monstrosities
roam free In Search of Life how could
this have happened Joto's family had
been on some Bizarre Adventures but this
one was proving to be the most bizarre
of all the sun now designated SCP 001
was burning with intense bright red
light and an anomalous level of heat it
beat down on the world below like an
evil and sadistic god of the desert the
entire world was at the mercy of these
oppressive solar rays and high
temperatures were just the beginning
from the looks of it any living thing
exposed to the Rays of SCP 001 would
quickly dissolve into a horrible gooey
substance that would ooze towards other
organisms in an attempt to absorb them
into its biomass basically it was like a
zombie apocalypse straight out of an
Easy Bake Oven the Stardust Crusaders
had been passing through this city on
their Globe trotting Adventure only to
find that morning had brought with it a
disaster the likes of which had never
been seen before by midafternoon when
the sun was highest in the sky most of
the people had already been converted
into slime monsters and those who fled
into the Shadows found themselves
relentlessly hunted down and absorbed
only the stand users of juro's group who
were already on the lookout for strange
happenings had been clever enough to
pick up on the situation immediately
they had been the subject of many
unusual Supernatural attacks over the
course of their Journey so the initial
anomalous effects of SCP 001 seemed to
be another routine brush with an enemy
hey Juro this has to be the effect of an
enemy stand right Joseph said what are
you stupid or something old man spat
Jean Pierre ponre the Frenchman was ever
the impulsive one and he always found
something to complain about when a woman
wasn't present he was selectively polite
one might say it was fitting given the
fact that his stand silver Chariot took
the form of a sword wielding Knight and
its reaction speed was the fastest of
any of the Stardust Crusaders you think
one stand could do all this pner was
adamant about making his point jro's
fellow High School classmate nyaki
kakoen was the next to speak pulner keep
your voice down we can't be sure it's
not a stand but either way those flesh
monsters are looking for us kako and was
young than pner but tended to carry
himself with more composure this likely
had something to do with the fact that
herent green was the group's most
technical stand and often used for
reconnaissance what do you think avidol
kakan continued you're the expert here
Muhammad Abdul a fortune teller who
possessed a stand that controls fire
magicians red was often knowledgeable
about the supernatural a stand this
powerful would have to be limited in the
range it could affect abdol said what we
have to do is get further away from this
area then we'll see if the strange
sunlight Fades but what if the user is
following us Joseph interjected how will
we know we aren't putting more people at
risk Mr joar we can't win this battle
without more information abdol replied
kakun your hant green has the longest
range send it to scout for a place
outside of the stand's reach our stand
shouldn't be visible to those
transformed humans and the heat from the
sunlight won't affect something without
mass friendly reminder to those of you
at home unfamiliar with the properties
of stands stands are spectral entities
formed from the soul of the user and are
essentially superpowered ghosts without
physical presence as such they won't be
affected by SC SCP 001 the way a living
thing would now back to this Bizarre
Adventure right kakun nodded heroin
green kakun summoned his stand and began
threading heroin Green's long stretchy
body throughout the ruins as far as it
could go the young man concentrated
Looking Through The Eyes of his stand as
Co and his St search for the end of the
anomalous effects of SCP 001 pner
continued to complain as usual so we're
still not sure what's going on but from
what I've heard you're already calling
it a stand did I get that right afol PF
grumbled do you have any better ideas PF
abdol said sternly Iggy barked Iggy the
last member of the Stardust Crusaders he
was a Boston Terrier who commanded a
sand manipulating stand known as the
fool Iggy didn't really have much to add
to the conversation but he liked to be
heard listen said Joseph joar when I was
a younger man I actually did go
head-to-head with some terrifying beings
who might be able to turn people into
monsters like these but every single
time the sun was the enemy of those guys
nobody is interested in hearing your
stories right now old man jotoro chided
his grandfather meanwhile far from where
the Stardust Crusaders were hiding out
heroin green was reaching the limits of
its effective range and seeing no no
sign of an end to the anomalous effects
kakan was baffled could it be true that
the entire world had been affected by
the frightening ability of the sun now
that it was SCP 001 if that was true
then the apocalyptic Wasteland was more
than just the work of an enemy stand
user this would mean that the son itself
had become the enemy of all life kakun
wondered about his family back in Japan
would they manage to survive this
terrible catastrophe he couldn't help
but hope that the was some way out of
this utter Devastation even though the
information gathered by a stand told him
otherwise kakun with through hant green
and brought his companions up to speed
however hard it was to accept the world
as they knew it was Gone with the
Daybreak P was beside himself in sadness
while abdol and Joseph exchanged a
meaningful glance for once Iggy's bad
attitude subsided and the dog simply
whispered only joto remained determined
to carry on good grief would you all get
a hold of yourselves jotoro said we'll
remain human as long as we aren't caught
in that light so I'll use star Platinum
to Tunnel our way underground jotoro
star Platinum was a short-range stand
but in terms of raw power it was off the
charts its punches could easily tunnel
through solid rock and create a
Subterranean passageway for the
Crusaders to retreat to a safer area
that a boy jotoro Joseph exclaimed we'll
make our daring Escape mole style jotoro
nodded and called star Platinum shouting
its signature battlecry of or or Star
Platinum smashed through the earth below
instantly creating the entrance to a
tunnel at that exact moment every flesh
monster in the nearby vicinity turned
its attention towards the sound the
stand users had to move quickly because
they would soon be completely surrounded
oh my God shouted Joseph in his usual
way as a couple of Flesh monsters began
to enter the ruined building luckily
pner and avdal sprung into action and
summoned silver Chariot and magicians
red to fend off the flesh zombies silver
Chariot delivered an inescapably fast
Fury of Sword strikes to one of the
monsters while magician's red burned
them away with its Supernatural Flames
the two men high-fived at a job well
done just then the wall next to them
burst open revealing a new monster and
caused the sun's Rays to enter into the
building's interior with split-second
intuition avall pushed P further into
the Shadows the Frenchman tumbled
backwards into the hole jotoro made and
before he could get his bearings he
caught a glimpse of avdal being absorbed
into the monster's Mass avdol he cried
out but it was too late avdal was
already starting to show signs of
transformation into an ooike zombie
himself the fortune teller breathed in
deep and called the name of his stand
with determined fervor magician's red
before abdall could be fully taken by
the slime he unleashed the totality of
his Firepower on every zombified life
form within range its destructive heat
enhanced by the dryness of the
atmosphere abdal turned back to his
friends and gave them a heartfelt thumbs
up before he disappeared into the Flames
pner cried out for his friend again with
tears in his eyes but Ken and Joseph
grabbed him and made their way deeper
into the tunnel as badass and heroic as
it was Abdul's sacrifice wouldn't keep
those hordes of monsters at Bay for long
while kakin and Joseph dragged a crying
p through the underground Escape Route
jro and igy were already at the front of
the group using a combination of star
platinum's digging ability and Iggy sand
manipulation to stabilize the tunnel the
Stardust Crusaders were deep beneath the
surface of the Earth now so a Caven
could be a real problem we have to go
back P shrieked adol needs our help it's
too late pmer Joseph said with grim
conviction abdol is gone we we don't
know that for sure P carried on let me
go but kakin and Joseph held on to P
tightly and continued to drag him down
the passageway hoping not to lose him to
this daytime nightmare as well on the
inside jotoro was shaken by the loss of
one of his companions but nobody would
have been able to tell by looking at his
stoic exterior he was solely focused on
keeping the tunnel expanding so that he
and the remaining Crusaders could
survive this ordeal together suddenly a
noise from the opposite end of the
passageway put the group on high alert
like a flood of liquefied horror the
flesh monsters had begun pouring
themselves into the pit and were now
moving towards the group inch by inch oh
no Joseph shouted he loosened his grip
on pner and both of them immediately
booked it towards jotoro and Iggy kakin
however stood in place and braced
himself he didn't like it but he knew
what he had to do right now his stand
had the ability to stop these things but
first he had to slow them down Emerald
Splash kakun shouted prompting heroin
green to launch a stream of concussive
green gemstones from its hands as
planned the attack slowed the Slime
monsters down kin was then able to put
the second part of his plan into effect
he identified what appeared to be a face
on the monster in front and sent herant
green to make its way inside the
creature's body this was his stand's
most terrifying ability and one cck in
seldom used heroin green had the power
to control the bodies of other physical
entities from within once his stand had
established control kin forced the
massive ooze to stop in place instantly
plugging the tunnel and preventing the
rest of the monsters from getting any
closer how long could he keep this up he
didn't know but because of heroin
Green's properties as a remote stand
calun was able to run and rejoin jotoro
and the others at the front of the
tunnel the tether between himself and
his stand was stretched stretching
farther by the minute but he dared not
let his control of the oozing entity
slip lest he and his companions suffer
the same fate as abdol before long
jotoro felt a different sort of surface
at the front of the tunnel rather than
Earth it was brick with one punch from
Star Platinum he smashed through and
into what appeared to be an abandoned
subway station the power was still on
though most of the lights had faded it
was fortunate that there was no natural
sunlight in this place as everyone's
eyes adjusted to the light the stand
users crossed the tracks and made their
way onto the somewhat safer area pner
drifted over to the magazine chaos
searching for signs of anyone behind the
counter there was nobody here and igy
soon helped himself to some of the
coffee flavored chewing gum at the
concession stand the dog couldn't resist
his favorite snack after all jot stood
by the tracks as if Waiting for a Train
while cocken did his best to maintain
his hold on the monsters further behind
them in the tunnel with a bit of search
searching Joseph found a large portable
music player designed for CDs also known
as a boom box with the use of his
divination Focus stand hermit purple
Joseph created purple thorny Vines which
weave their way into the wires of the
device and generated a psychic message
hermit purple could usually be counted
on to provide more detail about a
situation but its powers were limited by
the device used to gain the information
in this case the CD within the boom box
had a copy of the Beatles famous 1969
album Abby Road so hermit purple's
message to Joseph came out as a garbled
but oddly appropriate rearrangement of
the lyrics to Here Comes the Sun little
darling I see their faces slowly
melting little darling it seems like
years since it's been all right here
comes the
[Music]
sun Here Comes the Sun
and I say I feel I've been slowly
melting sun sun sun here it comes oh my
God Joseph said to himself quietly just
then kakin felt the body that heroen
green was controlling give way
apparently the pressure of so many other
ooze monsters had been too much for it
to hold back and now these things were
barreling down the tunnel towards the
Crusaders rather than pulling heroin
green back completely Ely kin Unleashed
his Emerald Splash over and over again
in an attempt to force a cave in but the
creatures were too resilient and their
ooz likee structures meant they could
squeeze past mere rocks in their path
kin told the rest of the group that it
was time to leave and as if on Q a train
began to pull into the station
unfortunately the crazy train pulled
into the station with several Cars full
of oo zombies ready to grab the poor
team and drag them into the sun there
was no way out but up the stairs back
into the sunlight they had done
everything possible to escape from as P
joto Joseph and Iggy did their best to
fend off the attacking creatures using
their stands kakin made one last ditch
attempt to contain the monsters he
stretched hant green down to its most
basic form a series of long green
fibrous strings and created a net to
ensnare the creatures while the uses
could still seep its way through its
wiry form Kaki rigged his stand to set
off an emerald Splash on every bit of
anomalous goo that made it pass the
Net's defenses it was a sustainable and
effective wall against the monsters
using both the tensile strength of the
stand and its energy attacks to
effectively sty their progress there was
only one problem in order to maintain
this Perfect Defense kakin would have to
stay behind I'll hold them go on without
me kakin said Kaki Owen Joseph shouted
as the rest of them ran as fast as they
could out of the subway having
effectively lost two members of the
group The Stardust Crusaders were low in
spirits looking up through the subway
exit they could see that they would soon
be in contact with the sunlight meaning
that even their survival would become
unlikely but joto wasn't about to give
in he grabbed Iggy and held the dog out
in front of him all right Iggy it's now
or never either show us you can be a
team player or be the first to turn into
one of those blob monsters Iggy
struggled in joro's grip but to no avail
the dog knew that jotoro was serious so
in an act of self-preservation that was
unusually generous of him Iggy used the
fool to stir up the sand on the ground
above into a gigantic Shady sand Dome
moments later he compressed it into a
compact Fortress of sand Iggy's Moving
Castle as it were no light could enter
this Fortress but because of the
granular nature of sand oxygen was
flowing freely the Stardust Crusaders
now had a method of travel in this world
torn apart by a SCP 001 of course there
was still the matter of dealing with the
flesh creatures outside even if the
Fortress of sand could move across the
surface without sunlight getting in the
surrounding ooes could still impede its
progress with the help of all three of
jotoro Joseph and pner stands a solution
soon became clear Joseph would use
hermit purple on the sand to Divine the
location of any approaching threats
while J and P would Patrol the outside
of the miniaturized Fortress with star
platinum and silver Chariot respectively
that way whenever a flesh creature got
too close the two attack type stands
could unleash full force barges to knock
them away the next thing to do was for
Iggy to increase the speed of the sand
construct by adding Wheels to it it was
like a gigantic sand monster truck
zooming through the ruins with a
platinum brawler and a silver Knight
repelling anything that came too near
what once Iggy gained enough velocity
with the fool Joseph used hermit purple
to discern the location of a bit of
rubble shaped conveniently like a ramp
the sand castle vaulted off the ramp and
into the air while Iggy augmented his
creation once again with a pair of
gigantic gliding wings now they were
soaring out of the reach of the flesh
monsters Joseph and PF shared sympathies
over the loss of their two important
friends avdal and kakin had both bravely
given themselves to protect the team and
none of the Crusaders would be here if
it wasn't for them jro focused on
helping Iggy pilot the sand glider using
star Platinum to kick the ground
whenever the vehicle got too low nobody
was sure what they would encounter next
in the Daybreak or what Bizarre
Adventures were yet to unfold but they
had each other and for now that was
enough you all remember the story one of
the most epic sprawling action-packed
tales in the entire Multiverse The Saga
of Petro Wilson and the CP 5000
exclusion suit he went through an
unimaginable hell to reset the universe
and save the world from an SCP
Foundation that had seemingly lost its
mind and an unprecedented International
Mass Containment Breach that had the
stated goal of wiping out the human race
it was one of the most horrifying
possible timelines imaginable and we
should all be thankful for Petro's
struggle and sacrifice or should we
after all there are two sides to every
story each with its own perspective and
insight one side of the coin was Petro a
man willing to do anything to return
normaly to the human race on the other
side was a familiar yet wholly
unexpected face SCP
682 in our original telling of the SCP
5000 Odyssey you may have noticed
passing mentions of SCP 682 here in
there it was one of those thousands of
anomalies Unleashed across the world to
wreck terrible havoc on all of us but
what you may not have known is that SCP
682 was one of the few intelligent
entities that weren't surprised by the
sudden turn taken by the SCP Foundation
or indeed The World At Large SCP 682
knew something like this was inevitable
as soon as human beings found out about
it that's right it the entity behind all
the pain and misery of SCP 5000 and
today thanks to the inner thoughts of
none other than SC CP 682 itself you
will understand what it's all about and
why the SCP Foundation took such severe
action against it but in order to truly
understand this and the role that SCP
682 plays in it we need to get back to
the beginning two Foundation projects
with wildly different research
implications project Numa and project
dearon the first involved using cutting
edged technological advancements to map
out the human psychosphere and
understand the psychic web that connect
us all the latter was an attempt to
explore what happens after death and
perhaps even gains some control over its
processes but as is often the case when
Mankind dabbles in Arcane questions
better left unexplored the SCP
Foundation didn't like the answers they
found the rotten fruit of project deang
was SCP 201718 also known as what
happens after death if you're already
familiar with this one then there's a
good chance a chill just went down your
spine it's wildly considered one of the
most disturbing anomalous discoveries
ever and a member of the 05 Council
who'd already experienced it decided to
submit himself for Eternal torture at
the hands of SCP
106 just so he could avoid it according
to SCP 201718 after death there is no
Heaven no hell and no Oblivion the human
consciousness endures in the most
horrifying way possible it remains
bonded to its decaying Earthly body
feeling the the slow Agony of rot for
eternity unable to speak unable to move
unable to scream but fully aware as
everything they once were purifies and
Withers away and cremation isn't an
escape here it's worse every molecule of
Ash your body is reduced to will cry out
in silence echoing around the empty
Halls of your fragmented soul forever
with something this utterly horrifying
the natural follow-up questions are why
does this happen and For the Love of All
that is good and pure on this Earth is
there any way to stop it this brings us
to project Numa the one that's even more
closely associated with the events of
SCP 5000 the foundation's attempts to
map out the human psychosphere resulted
in a world shattering Discovery
something was living in there the entity
the powerful nameless creature we've
been referring to as it it lives in so
many of our heads watching waiting and
of course feeding the main question here
is on what prior to the discovery that
changed everything in the world of SCP
5000 the only being that truly knew was
SCP 682 itself melting away in its acid
tank Bound by reinforced restraints
hurting bored hating imagine for a
second what the life of SCP 682 is like
it isn't the most dangerous of the
anomalies out there the are devour of
Worlds and Scarlet Kings more happy to
crush our whole world in their claws nor
is it the most sadistic a being like SCP
106 offers a far more painful death than
being quickly mauled crushed or eaten by
the hardto destroy reptile and despite
this the foundation expends countless
resources in trying to murder it on a
constant basis it has been burnt melted
eaten alive drowned slashed beaten
dissected suffocated erased from
existence set upon by by Nightmare
creatures torn to shreds on an atomic
level and even more terrible termination
attempts than you can possibly imagine
we've made several videos on the subject
and even we have barely scratched the
surface of the pain inflicted on SCP 682
by the SCP Foundation even in its
default State SCP 682 is constantly
submerged in hydrochloric acid eating
away at it forever does that remind you
of anything else we've been talking
about you might wonder how SCP 682 can
with stand this level of constant
torture without completely losing its
mind to put it very simply 682 takes a
great deal of satisfaction in knowing
that what every human has to contend
with after death is far worse than the
tortures it expected to endure at the
pathetic hands of these doomed human
fools it already knew what project Numa
discovered it already knew about it the
entity it felt the constant suffering of
the teeming billions of dead in the
world around it and it found it
disgusting an interesting choice of
words and a favorite for SCP 682 but
also for the captured SCP Foundation
agent Samuel Ross during SCP 5000 as we
discussed briefly in our SCP 5000
coverage something happened that aligned
the perspectives of the SCP Foundation
with that of the Monstrous reptile that
they had taken such pleasure in
tormenting what on Earth could cause the
Protectors of humanity to suddenly
change their tune like this there are
other little Clues embedded in pierro's
terrifying SCP 5000 experience you may
remember a strange and frightening scene
where a foundation field commander went
down a row of foundation soldiers
stabbing each of them with a large
combat knife and none of them reacted
until one did at which point his comrade
set upon him like Mad Dogs and killed
him displaying an uncharacteristic level
of Swift brutality and then there are
the classified files from the 05 Council
and the Ethics Committee led by chairman
odongo Tani it goes without saying that
the 05 Council and the Ethics Committee
don't really see eye to eye on anything
but the results of project Numa changed
that the following is classified
conversation between a member of the 05
Council namely 05- one and chairman
tajani trying to comprehend the horror
of their Discovery my hand shake as I
hold the document this is confirmed he
nods we got the report from Numa staff
yesterday it's everyone even us even us
Tani to think I'd find myself agreeing
with that damn lizard what do we do you
know what we have to do we'll have to
disseminate a cure I think among
Personnel before we get things underway
it'll try to stop us otherwise God help
us one don't be like that Tani that's it
talking and one more incredibly telling
quote from a member of the SCP
Foundation picked up by Petra Wilson
during SCP 5000 once you realize you're
not supposed to feel pain there's
nothing to be afraid of anymore is it
all coming together now while each
participant here only has a part of the
puzzle between us all we can see the
full picture The Entity it has inhabited
the human psychosphere for as long as
we've existed it's a kind of
metaphysical parasite attached to the
entire human race and what it feeds on
seems to be the after effects of pain
and like all efficient parasites like a
tapeworm that induces hunger and its
victim so that I can have more food
delivered unto itself The Entity
cleverly perpetuates it own food source
that's right it is the very cause of all
pain Humanity was never actually meant
to feel it it's a lie we've told
ourselves well not quite something we
told ourselves but something it told us
it induced pain and tricked us all into
believing that it was a natural
component of our existence all the while
it fed on us sustained itself on the
suffering that it had seated within our
hearts and souls the foundation
discovered this and was horrified but of
course the pain it caused for the living
was only part of the equation through
the revelations of project deang another
thing that as CP 682 was able to know
intuitively we can complete this puzzle
and find the terrible truth the truth
being that it is not only behind the
suffering we experience in life but SCP
2718 the even greater suffering we
experience in death for Millennia it has
groomed Humanity into a perfect all you
can eat buffet of dismal pain and
suffering and until recently they'd been
so blissfully ignorant of the horrible
fate that awaited them on the other side
the foundation saw only one solution to
this problem but it certainly wasn't a
nice one in order to save themselves and
all of humanity from a truly wretched
eternity they' need to distribute a cure
among themselves the mimetic key phrase
Harden your hearts and then go about
Exterminating every human being still
infected by it only that would
presumably Purge the monster from the
psychosphere forever and Grant Humanity
both painless lives and restful deaths
it was a horrible thing done for the
best of reasons the cured Foundation
Personnel started to notice the horrible
background noise of suffering all around
them they now understood how the reptile
felt to call all of this disgusting
would be a grave understatement if
anything could help them execute this
plan of mass mercy killing it would be
SCP 682 a scaly Survivor in Disguise all
long SCP 682 was surprised to see the
day arrive alarms went off across the
containment site his acid tank was
drained his restraints unlocked a group
of unarmed unprotected researchers
entered the room he saw into their eyes
they changed they were free and for the
first time in decades he was free too
they explained to him that they'd been
acquainted with his old enemy The Entity
it they understood his malice his
disdain for once they were suddenly
joined in a shared goal they needed to
kill them all they needed to purge The
Entity from the psychosphere forever in
the words of the foundation researchers
they would need to exterminate everyone
who was infected and SCP 682 would need
to help the heart to destroy reptile
relishing the opportunity replied I will
do my part and for a brief window of
glorious time it was free with no threat
of recapture it rampaged through the
world gleefully slaughtering scores of
people it was in its element taking part
in the mass extermination of the
infected every dead body added to the
pile was another blow struck against it
soon enough the world would be
disgusting no longer but of course
that's not how this story ended it had a
trump card Petro Wilson it guided him
all the way dragging him from Nightmare
to nightmare until he was eventually
able to reset the world and erase the
the discovery made by project Numa the
Slate was wiped fully clean and because
of it we are forever ignorant of the
terrible fate awaiting us all after
death and the monster lurking in our
psychosphere that feeds off of every
morsel of suffering you can thank Petro
Wilson for that nasty little gift only
one entity truly remembered what had
happened SCP 682 of course they had
their chance to save themselves and they
ruined it so close yet so far from that
day onward SCP 682 found the foundation
not only disgusting but disappointing
screams filled the cold night air
drowned out by the panicked gunshots and
the vicious growl of something inhuman a
being from who knows where a creature
that the agents surrounding it were
woefully underprepared to capture
General mcoy barks at the soldiers to
concentrate their fire on the Beast his
men those who hadn't already fallen
turned and trained their guns on the
creature squeezing their trigger fingers
bullets spewed out of their weapons a
hail of gunfire that sped towards their
target only to miss as it suddenly
vanished from the spot it had been
standing only a split second earlier
their bullets passed through the thin
air left in its wake shredding several
nearby trees one of the men threw his
gun to the ground turned heel and
sprinted away as fast as he could he had
hadn't known what he was signing on for
when he was recruited by a shadowy upand
cominging organization he'd just been
flattered to be head hunted for his
combat skill and agreed to be one of the
new organization's first field agents if
he'd known it would result in him facing
off against a demon near a rural road in
Guatemala and he would have stayed in
the regular military the fleeing agent
suddenly stopped in his tracks instantly
feeling sick it was the most
Indescribable type of sickness worse
than any he he had ever felt in his
entire life he dropped to the ground his
pants from running away replaced with
heaves as his entire body seemed to have
suddenly turned against him his head was
burning at first he thought he'd run too
fast too quickly and was overheating
underneath his military fatigues and
helmet but he was no slouch recruited
for being in Peak physical condition
such as he was never in his life had the
agent ever felt this bad the heat from
his forehead was unbearable a fever
running rampant as its Vision began to
blur everything was spinning that
unsettling imbalance that comes with
severe nausea rapidly taking hold of the
Fallen agent then the monster came back
through unfocused eyes he looked up at
The Tall featureless Face of the
creature as it looked down at him he was
helpless hurling and shuttering barely
able to stand if someone had brought a
Geer counter with them it would be
ticking loudly and frequently if they
help it near the agent and that somehow
was about to be the least of his
problems the creature opened up its
mouth the only facial feature that
occupied its head past its few remaining
teeth was a Milky blue orb the same
thing that had been visible right before
the creature itself wasn't as the agent
from his place on the ground caught
sight of the pale eyeball in the
monster's throat something started
pulling his body in on itself it was
like falling except gravity was acting
on different parts of his body at
different speeds at different times his
arms and legs folded inwards towards his
Center of mass making the agent scream
out in pain as his body collapsed he
folded into himself like origami Peace
by agonizing peace until there was
nothing left hearing the man's scream
General mcoy and the others broke
through the tree line flashlight beams
Illuminating the creature the general
yelled again for his man to shoot it
trying to hide his fear with him animal
rage it snarled at them as they raised
their guns once more then leaped towards
them ready for another kill in the years
to come the successors to these men and
their fallen colleagues would be the
world's foremost experts in situations
like this the capture and containment of
anomalies would one day be a more
streamlined process rather than the
blood bath currently unfolding in the
small gual in town dying at the hands of
what locals had thought to be a demon
were some of the earliest precur cursors
to the SCP Foundation humble beginnings
indeed the creature was eventually
captured by the early precursor version
of what would one day be the SCP
Foundation at this time in their history
the organization had far fewer resources
and reach than they would one day have
at their disposal they didn't even have
the SCP numerical designation system
that has since become synonymous with
the organization and the various
anomalies they keep contained as a
result this so-called demon was or
originally classified as number 8624 3
a-001 however it would later be known as
SCP 001 or one of the anomalies to share
that designation at least SCP 001 itself
was an abnormally thin humanoid creature
with gray brown skin its emaciated bone
and muscle structure didn't match any
known species it sported dark claws at
the tips of its arms with both legs
terminating in similar sharp black
points rather than Paws or feet most
striking was its face or rather its lack
of one the creature's head was spherical
with a lipless mouth reaching halfway
around its circumference within was a ma
of 21 teeth each spaced randomly apart
and either chipped broken or rotting it
possessed one eye or what was at least
believed to be an eye in the form of a
large milky blue sphere in its throat
with no pupil or ey
as was discovered in initial testing by
Dr Herman ker For Whom the ubiquitous
ker class designation was named SCP
00001 was able to create micro
singularities using its single milky
blue eye it could deploy these as a
means of teleporting itself out of
Harm's Way or for offensive attacks that
could cause a human body to collapse in
on itself these singularities often also
produce the nasty side effect of
emitting lethal amounts of deadly
radiation that could not only cause
damage to the surrounding area but also
would fatally poison anyone nearby as a
result It is believed one of these micro
singularities was responsible for the
untimely death of Dr ker however Ker's
Research into SCP 00001 was at least
able to produce solutions for keeping it
contained it was discovered that SCP
00001 could not teleport through lead
and would display signs of extreme
sickness and fear when exposed to high
levels of heat and humidity or bright
flashing lights strobe lights were used
to induce this sicken State and in this
state the creature was unable to form
harmful singularities Dr Ker's death
also ushered in the affir mention
creation of the ker class designation
for anomalous creatures or artifacts
that are extraordinarily tough to keep
safely contained in fact if any of this
account is to be believed the very
Discovery and capture of SCP 001 was the
impetus for the entire SCP foundation's
approach to researching and containing
anomalies in the days before the likes
of Dr krai or Dr cleff before Infamous
anomalies such as SCP 682 the hard to
destroy reptile or scp096 the shy guy
were even known about things were well
pretty uneventful for the newly formed
Foundation as you can probably imagine
but none exemplified this better than
Harold woodu and an uninteresting man
living an uneventful life or as
uneventful as one could get when their
job was working for the foundation
during this crucial period of the SCP
foundation's early history as the
anomalous research and containment
organization was taking its first steps
towards protecting the people of the
world Harold was Finding himself bored
already with his work Harold was a
senior archist at a small site in sloths
pit Wisconsin this was before the
foundation had secret facility situated
all over the world and even the infamous
site 19 as it is today had yet to be
established for now it was known only as
adx-1 19 the oldest Foundation site on
record and records were herold's entire
working life he was in charge of
maintaining the earliest reports of
anomalous activity and the inner
workings of the fledgling Foundation One
Day Harold received a letter from adrx
19 unfamiliar with the designation he
ran a check through the records and
discovered that the site had been
established before the foundation had
even gotten its name the letter
contained an update for the senior
archivist having grown obsolete in its
own age adrx 19 was being closed for
Good and that meant all of the anomalous
entities and objects stored there would
soon be shipped off to be stored
elsewhere the first package arrived at
the site Harold was stationed at not
long after he walked briskly out to meet
the delivery officer as he wheeled the
large wooden crate through the bay doors
didn't take the archist long to realize
what exactly he had now been given the
ownership of and charged with protecting
the crate even came complete with
relevant case files to accompany it
stamped on one side of the box was a
series of numbers and letters that
shocked Harold when he read them SCP 001
he exchanged a confused look with the
man who had delivered the anomaly who
just laughed when he saw Harold's
expression you in here he asked SCP 001
is dead the creature's death had come on
the the heel of a number of significant
changes made by the foundation hups
these decisions were ultimately both the
direct result of the encounter with SCP
001 in Guatemala were also changes that
would ultimately shape the foundation
into its modern iteration the first of
these was the introduction of the
numerical designation system providing
each anomaly with an SCP number formerly
designated as number 8624 3
a-001 the creature that was captured and
research by Dr ker was announced to be
reclassified as SCP
00- originally the number attached to
each SC SCP denoted the order in which
they were encountered by the foundation
however the overseer Council believed
this posed a security risk offering too
much information about their operations
to any potential adversaries as a result
the use of SCP 001 designation started
to be applied in a slightly different
way a number of anomalies were then
grouped under the umbrella designation
of SCP 001 some of these were real
anomalies and amongst the earliest that
the foundation encountered others were
entirely fake and used as a cover for
the real SCP 001 nobody not even within
the foundation itself was ever told
exactly how many files fell under the
SCP 00001 umbrella or indeed which was
the real one the anomalies included the
gate Guardian a towering Colossus of
pure energy wielding a flaming sword
believed to be the biblical Angel
guarding the Garden of Eden the Scarlet
King an extradimensional Tyrant that
longs to conquer our reality a group of
36 individuals capable of neutralizing
anomalies even the SCP Foundation itself
is considered one potential SC
scp1 and among them is also the creature
from Guatemala otherwise known as the
Prototype the same creature whose
inhuman bones were now in a box before
Herald the senior archist had long
longard legends about what exactly SCP
001 might be was a question often
whispered among Foundation staff who
were curious what the first anomaly
might be but didn't have the security
clearance to know the truth rumors
spread that SCP 001 was more powerful
than any other anomalies in containment
that the capture or discovery of it was
either the reason for the foundation
ever forming or it was one of their
greatest failures meant to be kept their
closest guarded secret something far too
terrible to comprehend you might think
that now being presented with an answer
would give Harold relief So Many Wonders
and haunting queries about SCP 001 were
put to rest but instead as he opened up
the wooden crate and looked at the pile
of strange bones inside it had the
opposite effect none of it was the
interesting answer that Harold and many
others had hoped for if anything it was
a huge disappointment all that
speculation surrounding the mystery of
SCP 001 what it was was where it had
come from why it was kept so secret was
this the answer was just the first thing
that the SCP Foundation had put into a
box according to the foundation's own
internal reports the Prototype monster
had been found lying still in its
containment chamber during a routine
inspection it wasn't moving at all even
armed guards couldn't get a reaction
from the creature the anomaly wasn't
breathing its heart having slowed to a
stop little was known about the
creature's biology but even then nothing
could be done to resuscitate it as far
as anyone could tell the anomaly known
as SCP 00- Cog had died of old age after
exhibiting movement that got gradually
slower and weaker and even less hostile
Behavior over the course of the previous
decade since its initial capture but yet
Harold was still dissatisfied with the
knowledge that this was SCP 001 he
became fixated on the case surrounding
it studying the files he was charged
with moving to storage he learned of the
few ways the creatures Discovery had
influenced the early foundation for
example the death of Dr ker being the
reason for the use of ker class in their
terminology still that didn't feel
nearly as important as Herold and others
had speculated that SC SCP 001 would be
there had to be something more to it and
for weeks following the arrival of the
creature's bones Harold could not stop
thinking about it something about all
this didn't sit right with him the
secrecy that the foundation shrouded SCP
1 and seemed like overkill for just a
monster the organization I had seen far
worse than the likes of the prototype in
the many years since at the time perhaps
it had seemed like the most dangerous
anomaly the foundation had encountered
if it really was the first then
technically at that time it would have
been the most dangerous if there were no
others to compare it to one night Harold
ventured into the archive and opened up
the box containing the creature's bones
using a crowbar he had to know had to
understand exactly what was so important
about this being cracking the wooden
crate open he removed the skull to
examine it the foundation hadn't even
had a chance to figure out what exactly
the creature was or where it had
originated from all they knew was it
could produce micro singularities and
lethal doses of radiation beyond that
the only other details came from the
Guatemalan locals who had encountered it
first they had called it a demon perhaps
it was the foundation would never know
for certain and it seemed to Harold that
they didn't care to know now that SCP
001 was dead and didn't seem to care
much before then either they were more
than happy to just discard it he
couldn't shake the feeling that there
was meant to be something important
about the creature Harolds couldn't help
it The Whispers surrounding SCP 001 all
indicated it was meant to be something
more significant than a cast aside pile
of bones the underwhelming reality he
was being presented with didn't match
the idea of SC BP 001 Harold examined
the skull closely in his hands turning
it around and around as he tried to
maybe spot something some important
detail that everyone else in the
foundation had failed to notice or some
of the puzzle that would explain what
was so important about this creature and
yet the more he looked the less he
learned Alas poor SCP 001 he said aoud
paraphrasing Hamlet of course what
Harold didn't know didn't possess the
clearance to know was that this wasn't
the only SCP 001 maybe the foundation's
lack of interest in the creatures
remains was all part of their plan to
keep the real SCP 001 a secret where
Harold only saw a box of Bones and a
disappointing answer to so many burning
questions the SCP Foundation saw their
system working exactly as intended the
sr47 sniper rifle slotted together
effortlessly even after so many years of
combat usage the weapon was in pristine
condition in all the time agent Harris
had owned the gun though the thousands
of times she' fired it not once had it
jammed and that was fortunate because
she had to move quickly in a clearing
about 300 M in front of her were their
targets capable of teleporting in a
split second she needed to be sure that
her team would be able to finish the job
quickly and efficiently she looked
through the scope slotted onto her rifle
and kicked out the bipod resting it on a
tree stump now she just had to wait for
the signal she looked all around the
marsh trying her best to spot her fellow
agents but they were also well
camouflaged even though she knew the
exact spot where they would be she
couldn't see anyone she'd always wanted
to see the Himalayas it had been on her
bucket list to climb Mount Everest as a
child but the world had changed since
then Mount Everest was gone in fact the
majority of Nepal had vanished replaced
by an enormous Marsh full all almost
exclusively of pink Ferns and Droopy
trees that seemed to Sag to one side
unable to support their own weight the
most striking natural wonder on planet
Earth had been replaced by a landscape
that was flat wet and alien agent Harris
curled her finger around the trigger and
took aim through her sights 2 minutes
passed then the gentle whistle of a
sparrow drifted over to her in the humid
air except of course it couldn't be a
sparrow to the best of her knowledge
Sparrow arrows had gone extinct with a
snarl of anger agent Harris squeezed the
trigger she felt the silent sniper rifle
kick her shoulder if they wanted War
they sure as hell would get it the
destruction of the world began in 2078
its designation wasp orange Das a and as
often happens with these kind of things
no one saw it coming the SCP Foundation
having dedicated decades to researching
potential World destroying events was
totally blindsided by what happened the
day the weasels showed up weasel you ask
that's right but before we explain a
question for you is something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
regardless if you have a clinical mental
health issue like depression or anxiety
or if you're just a human who lives in
this world who is going through a hard
time therapy can give you tools to
approach your life in a very different
way and that's why I'm excited to tell
you about today's sponsor betterhelp
better help's mission is to make therapy
more affordable and more accessive ible
and this is an important Mission because
finding a therapist can be really hard
especially when you're limited to the
options in your area better help is a
platform that makes finding a therapist
easier because it's online it's remote
and by filling out a few questions
better help can match you to a
professional therapist in as little as a
few days it's easy to sign up and get
matched with a therapist there's a link
in my description it's betterhelp.com
SCP explained clicking that link helps
support this channel but it also gets
you 10% off your first month of better
help so you can connect with a therapist
and see if it helps you and because
finding a therapist is a little like
dating if you don't really fit with that
therapist which is a common thing with
therapy you can easily switch to a new
therapist at no additional cost without
stressing about insurance who's in your
network or anything like that so if
you're struggling consider online
therapy with better help click the link
in the description or visit
betterhelp.com
SCP explained thank you again better
help for supporting this Channel and now
as we were saying about the weasels a
man called Harland stump was the first
human to make contact with the weasels
he was the groundskeeper at site 59
Harland was making his usual weekly
trips around the perimeter of the
courtyard on his ride along lawnmower
watching baseball on his phone all the
way when out of nowhere the aliens
appeared just 2 m in front of him a
squadron of 11 weasels materialized the
weasels designated SCP orange DB stand
at a minimum of 3 m tall with 16 legs
and an exoskeleton carpas they share a
resemblance with terrestrial insects
their bodies are segmented composed of a
head primary thorax secondary thorax
tessary thoracic cloy abdomen and tail
with a hard segmented shell covering
their backs and no apparent sensory
organs aside from a radula on their
heads they are an intimidating presence
most striking about them however is the
most delicate part of their appearance
on their facts each weasel has an array
of Flora growing in a kind of garden it
appears that each weasel has a different
array of flowers growing from their
backs understanding the meaning of these
Gardens can be difficult but it appears
the more extravagant it is the higher
ranking the individual weasel is the 11
weasels that appeared before Harland
stump each had a very vibrant Garden
indeed but no more so than the weasel
held a loft in an ornate Peloquin
Harland stumps stopped Mowing and stared
at the aliens for a approximately 13
seconds at which point he let out a sigh
pressed play on his baseball game and
continued mowing the lawn he spent too
many years groundskeeping site 59 to get
spooked by anything as harmless as giant
teleporting insects just three more
weeks and he would be retired until then
he was avoiding nonsense like the plague
except his phone had disappeared Harland
stared down at the empty space confusion
knitting his eyebrows together before
looking up and seeing the handset in the
hands of the alien sitting on its Regal
Throne the smartphone made a loud
screeching noise and then all of a
sudden began to flick between Snippets
of YouTube videos each clip lasting just
a couple of seconds after a moment Haron
realized that the alien was using the
videos to speak to him the words were
being picked out from all these
different videos to stitch together a
sentence barely H ho neighborino this is
foundation reports indicate Foundation e
locally the masters of the UN Universe
isn't that right darling question mark
Keen to finish his Mowing and avoid
further nonsense Harlin had to concede
that he should probably talk to these
aliens if only to get his phone back he
told them he liked the Gardens on their
backs why thank you gardening is kind of
our thing well quick question is your
species capable of
dying Haren G he'd been around long
enough to see where this was going the
conversation was brief Haron kept
glancing at his phone desperately hoping
that these aliens hadn't somehow broken
it and that it hadn't lost his place in
the match until all of a sudden Harland
stump disappeared as did his rideon lawn
mower his smartphone and a patch of lawn
replaced by a roughly 10 m circle of
Antarctic ice and snow no one is certain
yet how the weasels are able to do it
all that is known is that they can the
phenomenon came to be known as
juxtaposing matter from one location
could be instantaneously switched with
with matter from a different location it
is how the weasels first arrived on
planet Earth triggering the event of SCP
001 orange Dash orange Dash lasted for
Just 2 hours but it changed the course
of humanity Forever on the 29th of April
2078 48.5 2% of the Earth's habitable
surface area dematerialized and
rematerialized half a kilometer above
the South Pole cities and towns from all
across planet Earth one by one
disappeared and reappeared in the air
above the South Pole where they promptly
fell 500 M causing backto back seismic
events Washington DC Beijing and London
were targeted first followed by Tokyo
Delhi and then a number of Capital
Cities from Europe This 2-hour window
resulted in freak weather events as
minus 50° pockets of air kilometers
across replaced the disappearing cities
it is disputed as to who launched the
first nuclear warhead whether it was
done by accident out of fear or as a
strategic attack against a group of
weasels orange daset was simply too
chaotic and destructive for Humanity
ever to be able to know what happened in
that short period of time the result
however was a number of nuclear
explosions raging across the planet
before the cities in charge of launching
them were also transported to the South
Pole while the weasels were capable of
experiencing juxtaposition without any
apparent physical harm terrestrial life
forms were less fortunate during the
process of juxtaposition the bonds
between each and every cell are broken
while organic life does get transported
to the new location it undergos
immediate liquefaction not a single
earthborn life form has been observed
surviving a juxtoposition event in that
2-hour window 6.9 billion people were
killed Humanity had lost this event
triggered the use of project yellow an
emergency evacuation protocol that
occurs at the point where the survival
of the human race seems to be virtually
zero a small band of specially chosen
individuals TOS were evacuated to a
pocket Dimension where they were put
into cryosleep to wait until the Earth
was habitable once again in the days
following the events of orange Das a the
true Invasion began choosing the Sahara
Desert as their arrival point the
weasels started to appear in Legions
millions and millions of them filled the
Desert Sands and went about populating
their new planet but what was their
purpose well fortunately we have been
able to salvage a modest amount of data
that can inform us of why they're here
and and what their plans are the weasel
that first appeared to Harland stump
just outside site 59 has been designated
SC SCP orange prime it is believed that
this weasel in particular is their
leader whether Prime is simply the
leader of this Colony or The Wider
species is yet to be confirmed security
cameras were able to capture the
interaction as it took place within SC
159's grounds in their conversation
orange Prime explains their purpose to
Harland through YouTube clips on his
phone long story short weasel
have come from home world demension for
fulfill a long-standing mutual agreement
with Grandma this is one of many new
homes this is a pretty nice place for
weasles this land is my land from
California to the New York Islands from
the Redwood Forest to The Gulfstream
Waters this land was made for weasles
two Garden two Farm two create Beauty
two spread Good Vibes two cultivate two
remake two terraform etc etc since this
encounter no human has been able to get
close enough to Orange Prime to engage
the weasel in further conversation this
snippet of footage is all that Humanity
has to understand why this alien species
has slaughtered billions of us 4 months
later agent Harris lay flat in the
marshin fire firing her sniper rifle at
the weasels gathering in a clearing
ahead of them their operation looked
like Overkill it always did it was of
utmost importance that they strike
quickly and without Mercy sustained
heavy gunfire from all sides combined
with RPG fire and the use of incendiary
weapons made short work of the weasels
all of these weapons were necessary to
pierce the heavy armor that covered
their backs but that was the reason it
felt like Overkill it felt that way
because the weasels never fought back
there would not attack defend themselves
help their fallen allies or even beg for
their lives they would simply stand idly
by as they were gunned down that is
until the incendiary grenades arrived
the pink ferns filling the marshlands
caught fire and began to curl and smoke
heavily as soon as that happened the
weasels sprung into action quickly
splashing water onto the leaves trying
their best to save the plants the
incendiary grenades were not necessary
they did very little damage to the
weasel themselves the reason the platoon
used the grenades was that it was one
way they had found to distress their
Alien Invaders in any way it was a small
Revenge they could take for the billions
of people who had lost their lives over
the prior few months agent Harris pumped
five extra shots into the corpse of a
weasel before standing down and going to
examine her handiwork they had been
hunting orange Prime rumors had
suggested that their primary target had
been lurking in the Himalayan region but
that had obviously proven to be false
among all the bodies on the ground there
was no sign of the fearless leader
frustration boiled in Harris as she
kicked a corpse the thick shell hurt her
foot she must have broken her toe at
that moment a rustling noise came from
the other side of the trees soon dozens
more hundreds more weasels were walking
through the marsh in a split second her
platoon opened fire Tracer rounds lashed
through the trees and the orange glow of
fire danced in every direction but there
were more weasels many more of them
agent Harris felt her stomach knot as
she fired her rifle into the crowd there
were too many simply too many they were
going to run out of ammo before they had
a chance to shoot down each and every
one of them and she was right the
firefight lasted for 30 minutes before
the remaining Soldier ran out of
ammunition dozens of weasel bodies
littered the marsh floating in the water
dozens more weasel stood encircling the
group that's when the humming started
whenever a jux toos event occurs it is
always accompanied by the weasel's
humming to themselves it is unclear
whether this is the cause of the jux
deposition or simply a ritual that they
perform but every Soldier has come to
know that sound and each one of them
fears it in the pit of their stomach so
they started to disappear all around her
one by one replaced by puffs of cold air
with snowflakes still gently hanging in
the breeze the human population of
planet Earth dwindled as the weasel
population bloomed large swaths of the
planet were terraformed one by one to
make room for alien Flora the South Pole
became a large and larger Dumping Ground
for all the detrius that had once been
the most celebrated works of the human
race the Mona Lisa was torn and
forgotten buried under many kilometers
of concrete exposed sewage works and
apartment complexes and the situation
only got worse in October acting against
prior instructions from the foundation
the global ult Coalition launched
project Popco a 200 Megaton nuclear
warhead directly at a large weasel
population Center as the Warhead began
its descent the entire sky turned a
solid dark blue project Popco
immediately fell out of contact as did
all satellites that had been orbiting
the planet the sun moon and stars could
not be seen the entire sky was just a
uniform dark blue in a desperate attempt
to find out what was going on the
foundation launched a Mann rocket in the
direction of Popo's most recent
coordinates contact with the rocket was
lost after just 9 minutes this is the
most recent known account of events from
inside that rocket all of a sudden just
a few minutes into the the flight
warning alarm started going off all over
the cockpit the radar was picking up a
solid object blocking their path
gathering around the readouts the crew
came to a very quick conclusion that the
dark blue that had been filling the sky
was actually a solid object that was
encasing the Earth but rather than abort
the mission the crew decided to
persevere having witnessed so Much Death
and destruction over the previous year
they knew they would much rather go out
in crashing a rocket into a blue wall
than join the billions of humans
liquefied in a pile in Antarctica
closing their eyes bracing for impact
the crew Reed themselves for their now
inevitable deaths but it didn't come
instead the rocket was able to force its
way through the dense blue object
falling apart as it went Ground Control
lost contact with the ship nothing and
then a few seconds of audio the crew had
made it they had somehow managed to
pierce their way through the blue shell
that was surrounding their planet and
were out into not space the Earth the
entire planet had had been ju opposed
philan be the new welcome to an
exclusive behind the scenes look at
Heaven on May 12th 2588 The Entity known
as SCP ubu manifested in Kangas
Greenland like something out of the most
nightmarish Kaiju movie never made soon
after there was no more death but the
world was filled with such chaos and
despair that Humanity longed for that
Eternal release from its enormous
stomping feet to its cloa to its face
featureless save for a gaping grinning
devouring mouth The Entity was pure
malice with all the time in the world
ubu decimated the planet breaking the
spirit of mankind and raising every city
to the ground in the earlier days of
ubu's invasion when there was still dry
land and people still wanted to talk to
each other rather than joining floating
islands of Eternal chemically induced
Slumber they would commiserate about the
shared misery of the state of things oh
you ubu my daughter hasn't spoken to me
ever since that monster shoved my whole
body down her throat someone would say
another would pipe up trying to one up
the first man in sort of a trauma
Olympics didn't you see me in the news
ubu carried me around for a week
snacking on me every now and then like I
was his own personal Turkey Leg it was
hell but honestly part of me felt a
little bummed out when he threw me away
yet another person would chime in like
veterans swapping War Stories over a
drink at the bar ubu made me eat a pair
of my pants hold whole thing zipper and
all then he decided he thought that was
funny made me eat pair after pair after
pair of them rinse and repeat by the
time he got bored I had eaten probably
around 20 paars and sort of got a taste
for them after that everyone on the
planet had good reason to despise as CP
ubu but no one held more hate in his
heart for the pale Wicked creature than
Dr Lawrence mikal before the world was
turned upside down sometimes literally
Dr moud was a member of the mysterious
05 council at the SCP Foundation to be
specific he was
05-11 but that prestigious position at
the foundation couldn't protect him or
his loved ones from the wrath of ubu
when Dr moud was off duty ubu attacked
him and his wife first it impaled his
wife on a broom handle next it threw Dr
moud into an open pool of sewage in the
street then it bathed him in the filthy
water using his screaming wife as a
scrubbing brush all the while whistling
a horrible little bathtub song Centuries
after that awful experience as Dr moud
watched most of his colleagues give up
and choose the closest thing to death in
this broken world he became even more
determined to do something about it on
January 14th 3030 Dr mcod abandoned the
scps naith and his fellow 05 council
members in search of the scps Corn crate
an abandoned craft to the southeast it
wasn't an easy Journey rowing all the
way there in a Lifeboat never knowing
when the great white people Beast would
emerge from the water and choose him as
its next unfortunate play thing he could
see the scps corn cek still floating
there untouched but before he could row
any closer something collided with the
Lifeboat From Below snapping it in half
Dr macau's stomach dropped at the sight
of pale flesh but it was soon replaced
with relief when he saw that the thing
that had broken his lifebo was not in
fact ubu it was an injured narwhal
behaving erratically due to its wounds
the culprit was almost certainly ubu it
wasn't content to just torment humans
but instead must have been targeting any
life form that could feel pain and fear
in his own words Dr moud had put it at
least a mass extinction wouldn't have
made it that personal after the life
boat broke apart moud swam to the conre
exhaustion and cold straining his
muscles it took him 2 hours to reach the
abandoned cargo barge and containment
site but eventually he managed to climb
up over the side and get on board there
was one very special thing about the
corn crate the thing that made it worth
crossing the ocean in a fragile little
Lifeboat to find every anomaly that made
the ganam list the list of anomalies
considered too dangerous to abandon even
in an apocalyptic scenario was contained
on the corn crake if there was anything
left that the foundation or anyone else
hadn't tried to use to defeat ubu it
would be on that ship after taking a
little while to recover Dr moud and
embarked on an initial exploration of
The Craft all the staff were gone as he
had expected thankfully he still had his
05 ID card and it still worked like a
charm unlocking all of the automated
security systems on board a lot of what
he found was in Ruins but some things
had survived he found 10 hominid
replicators from SCP 2000 in perfect
working order there was a cage
containing the remains of SCP 2845 the
deer though ubu had done significant and
damage to it SCP 319 a curious device
was there contained in the space locked
vacuum chamber this one was notable for
its potential ability to destroy the
universe he found a couple of safe class
anomalies such as SCP yez crowd control
for the Practical Optimist and SCP FNA
the portable warehouse the latter of the
two was a portable door frame to a
pocket Dimension he also stumbled upon
SCP 001 Last Ride of the day an old
Prometheus Labs prototype of a time
machine and possibly most importantly he
found SCP
076 the coffin was open but Abel didn't
attack Dr maoud he wasn't consumed with
murderous rage and blood lust the way he
always was before instead he was just
sitting on the edge of the ship silently
staring at the sea when he spotted moud
he gave him a small wave and did nothing
else the centuries of a world without
death a world without killing without
victory in battle had taken its toll on
him for possibly the first time in his
eternal life Abel was depressed 9 days
after he first inspected the Corn Creek
mik began to formulate a plan he loaded
all the hominid receptors into SCP FNA
using a thankfully still working
forklift next he was able to unseal the
sealed portion of SCP 001 Last Ride of
the day and get his hands on the details
of the anomaly it read SCP is a 1 is
capable of temporally relocating to its
relative position 15,000 years prior to
activation this temporal displacement is
Divergent Paradox Irrelevant in other
words a separate timeline is created as
a landing point for example if an
occupant from timeline X were to murder
their parents in utero in Timeline y the
Y iteration of the occupant would no
longer exist but the occupant themselves
being from X would be unharmed when in a
fully active state scpu 001 deploys a 5
m High telescopic antenna that functions
as a coloo wave energy sink essentially
Colo waves could only be produced as a
byproduct of the universe suddenly being
exterminated and ZK class reality
failures produce the most Colo waves in
one of these scenarios SC SCP 001 would
be able to use these waves to go back in
time 15,000 years effectively resetting
reality to a point far before the
catastrophe happened
this information allowed him to put his
plan together to resurrect project
Beluga step one plant explosive charges
around SCP 319 step two hide anything
potentially useful against SCP ubu
inside of SCP FNA step three get into
the cockpit with SCP FNA and toe step
four raise the Colo sink and step five
blow the whole thing up 3 days later it
was time to put the plan into motion Dr
moud placed the charges around SCP 39's
vacuum chamber there was enough in place
to implode the walls of the vacuum
chamber he closed the bulkhead and began
deploying the Colo syn 10% 25% 30%
suddenly he could hear a loud crashing
sound the ship began to tilt oh no he
could hear the distant sound of menacing
Giggles the sync reached 45 57 but as
ubu grew closer he quickly overrode the
system to lower the sink 45% 30%
25% 10% ubu grew closer and closer and
as it approached it began to whistle the
tune it once used when it bathed moud
and his wife in the sewer ubu began to
pound against the blast door becoming
increasingly frustrated as it struggled
to break through suddenly another voice
cut through the air an unexpected one
SCP 076 Abel called out to maau
encouraging him to carry on while Abel
held the Beast back as Abel and yubu
engaged in an epic battle maow suddenly
remembered something there was an
Express deployment module for the Colo
syn with no time to waste he activated
it all at once he hit the Detonator and
then the year was
11,970 and the date was February 14th
13,960 years later the SCP Foundation
discovered something beneath a mound of
Earth and snow near the northern border
of Lapland Finland it was a shipping
container with a reinforced exterior the
interior of which could only be accessed
through a fortified bulkhead on one side
the words SCP 001 were written on the
side in black paint in spite of this the
object was given the designation as CP
848 a narrow winding tunnel through the
mound of Earth and snow was discovered
leading from the door to the outside
world the tunnel had significant wear
clearly having been used as a flip path
by someone but who well on April 12th
1993 the foundation got their answer SCP
848 bulkhead opened and a man stepped
out snapping his fingers and promptly
sealing the door behind him he was
designated pole 848 he was a 32-year-old
man of French Canadian descent answering
to the name of Dr Lawrence moud he made
a series of claims that the foundation
found dubious but noted it in the
official file for SCP 8848 just the same
these included but we're not limited to
SCP 848 is a time machine he held the
office of o 5-11 in the year 3030 from
an alternate timeline said timeline
experienced a modified Omega K Class end
of death scenario that coincided with
the invasion of a tiok class anomaly
known as SCP ubu SCP ubu was an
extremely dangerous and sadistic entity
who was capable of among other things
neutralizing SCP 169 and SCP 682 his
timeline's version of the foundation
launched project Beluga which resulted
in an impossible possible war with SCP
ubu that lasted 441 years Paul 848
deliberately sabotaged SCP 319 to act as
a power source for SCP 8848 thus
arriving in Lapland in the year
11,970 BC SCP ubu will arrive in
Greenland on May 12th
2588 Paul 848 was able to extend his
lifespan by sharing his Consciousness
between a Central Computer within SCP
8848 and several thousand bodies created
by his personal hominid replicators said
Consciousness sharing was achieved
through a book classified in the future
as SCP yez he wishes to assist the
foundation in the termination of SCP ubu
and has laid out a plan for its
termination as outlined in document 8048
dzeta there were of course concerns
about the man's legitimacy but after
mikad mentioned over 104 specific terms
and data points known only to members of
the 05 Council the foundation was was
forced to take him at least a little bit
seriously a motion was filed requesting
that poll 848 be allowed to assist the
foundation with the termination of SCP
ubu as per document 848 Zeta 054 voted
yay 057 abstained and the rest of the
council voted nay the motion failed to
pass a follow-up motion was filed in
response requesting that poll 848 be
allowed to assist the foundation with
their own strategy to respond to SCP ubu
05-10 5-4 057 and 05-10 abstained from
voting the rest voted nay the motion
failed to pass on April 14th 1995 Dr
Isaiah Henderson and pole 848 sat down
for an interview when asked to State his
name Dr mcau also recited a mimic
passphrase that when spoken by anyone
other than 05-11 of past or present
would cause them to burst into flames
the two men were at odds from the
beginning Dr maoud expressed dismay and
frustration that his proposal was
rejected meanwhile Dr Henderson
countered with the insistence that
macau's proposed plan was rejected for
posing an unnecessary risk to the
civilian public they debated for a
moment before Dr Henderson announced the
foundation's next plan of action Dr moud
was to be terminated the foundation
would proceed with its plans without him
at that point Dr Henderson terminated
moud as ordered he didn't count on one
thing though moud was no longer an
ordinary man bound to one body he hopped
into the body of a guard then into the
body of 054 to deliver a vital message
he had started this plan alone and was
ready to bring it to a close alone
project Beluga would continue with or
without the foundation's support Dr mow
returned to the bulkhead climbing back
inside and sealing it behind him he had
hoped to have the foundation behind him
he had hoped they would be allies in the
fight against the greatest evil mankind
ever encountered but they disappointed
him he had waited thousands of years
only for the organization he devoted his
life to to try and kill him well he
wasn't going to go down without a fight
this was bigger than the foundation
bigger than anyone and no living person
was as equipped to handle ubu as he was
so he resumed project Beluga as a
one-man operation he issued a mission
statement which read as follows on May
12th 2588 The Entity known as SCP ubu
invaded and pillaged human civilization
for no other motiv ation than cruelty
and selfish gratification shortly
thereafter project Beluga was founded as
a joint effort between the goblo cult
Coalition and the SCP Foundation for the
purposes of ubu's Destruction ubu is not
merely a threat to human safety he's an
a front to every positive and loving
Concept in the human consciousness
rather than our lives he seeks to
destroy our quality of life to State his
own sick desires think about it the
taste of ice cream playing with your dog
the way you felt after your first kiss
that is ubu's sworn Enemy No fate is too
cool for him no hatred is strong enough
when project Beluga Charter was signed
592 go officers and Foundation staff
were present at this ceremony our troops
numbered in the hundreds of thousands I
Dr Lin moud am the only surviving member
and always will be what I lack in
numbers is compensated thousandfold by
my weapons my mind my replicated bodies
and Leons of experience the following
record serves one purpose alone that
once justice has been brought to ubu
humans in The Shining and golden ubu
free future will understand that one
person can accomplish through the power
of hard science and ra motion entwined
in a perfect and indestructible braid
and while we are at it you are very
welcome over the next several hundred
years mow worked to secure ownership of
conaso Greenland through a project
Beluga civilian front he evacuated the
civilian population from the area then
spent a century constructing a super
weapon with 100 high yield nuclear
weapons heat amplification runes a
targeting Beacon for SCP dag and five
antimatter Gathering pods from SCP H&M
in place he was finally ready for ubu to
manifest again the helicopter lurched
and rumbled as it made its descent
through the veran insk mountain range
conditions were harsh with Fierce winds
ripping Through The Valleys at any point
a blizzard threatened to strike just
about managing to touchdown mobile task
force Lambda 9 was glad to be out of the
vehicle even if it meant stepping into
kneee snow there were eight operatives
in total early reconnaissance suggested
that they were the only people present
within a 5 km radius at least that
certainly what they hoped L9 operatives
1 through six all made their way up
through the mountain pass leaving seven
and eight guarding the chopper this was
a simple reconnaissance mission they
would need to search the bunker for any
signs of Life gather Intel and get out
hopefully before the snowstorm hit all
eight of them were kitted out with the
foundation's kter grade Cutting Edge
anti- cionic plating the operatives had
all been chosen carefully with L 9-1 the
leader being an experien Soldier serving
11 years in the unit he had capable
psionic Powers himself and approached L
9-2 who showed some of the same gifts
all of a sudden as the group rounded the
final pass and caught sight of the
facility both one and two experienced
severe migraines battered by the Russian
wind they had no choice but to get to
the bunker as fast as possible it looked
relatively unassuming a small concrete
slab sitting amongst the mountains the
six of them gathered around on either
side of the doors as number three forced
his way inside following standard
breaching Maneuvers the rest of the team
followed suit charging in through the
open doorway and immediately tipping
forward into an abyss they all landed
hard side by side on the slope some of
them rolling down clattering against
each other and eventually skidding to a
stop very gingerly the groups started to
get back to their feet and catch their
breath as the wind had been knocked out
out of all of them they weren't in a
research facility at all the Soviet
concrete walls they had been expecting
the old computers and the lab equipment
were all missing instead they were
standing in a void infinite and white
with no seeming end in any direction
beneath their feet and curling up above
them was an enormous double helix a
rainbow of colors weaving in and out of
one another it was like they had found
themselves standing on an enormous
strand of DNA floating all around them
were glowing orbs of light none of them
could tell how near or far these orbs
were they could have been close enough
to reach out and touch or they could
have been on the other side of the
universe and slowly one by one they
noticed the doorway that they had come
in through it was perpendicular to the
double helix and floating about 3 m
above their heads through it they could
see the snowy Russian Mountains their
only chance of Escape four murmured
something about needing to leave one
argued back at him they had no idea
whether that door was real or an
illusion they had no idea if they would
even be able to pass through it besides
it was 3 m above their heads and
floating out over the void it was risky
but for didn't care much about receiving
permission taking a few steps back
further down the double helix to get a
good run up he braced himself and
sprinted as fast as he could before
jumping and reaching for the open
doorway it was as if gravity was
suddenly much stronger as soon as he
stepped off the double helix four was
wrenched downwards tumbling and spinning
accelerating faster and faster he let
out a petrified screen that sent the
other operatives cowering there was no
bottom at least not as far as they could
see or hear for's body just got smaller
and smaller and his screams quieter and
quieter for several minutes until the
agents couldn't hear him anymore and yet
inside the heads of one and two the
psionic members of the group that
screaming sound only seemed to grow
louder December 25th
1962 a man walked briskly through the
West Berlin train station he shaved his
head the night before and trimmed his
beard down to a thick mustache dark
sunglasses covered his eyes and a fedora
was stepped forward he hoped that his
limp was convincing as he shuffled his
way through the crowds one advantage of
wearing dark sunglasses in the middle of
winter was that he could constantly scan
the faces of those around him looking
for anybody who looked Russian his train
had been delayed an hour outside of
Berlin the train had ground to a halt
German police officer officers had
walked the length of the carriages
checking everyone's tickets and
passports it felt like an eternity the
man was too old by this point to attempt
to run away besides running through
rural Germany in the snow didn't sound
like the best plan so he stuck to his
cover story and hoped against hope that
the fake passport he bought would be
convincing enough fortunately for him
the officer checked it he looked to be
about 18 years old the man doubted that
the boy would know a Russian passport if
it was finded by Nikita kushev himself
but shuffling through the station his
feeling of unease grew Russian deserters
had been poisoned all around him for the
prior 15 years a number of his own
colleagues had mysteriously gone missing
after feeling disenfranchised by the
Soviet agenda he was such a high-profile
Target that there was no way the KGB
wasn't actively hunting him down at that
very moment he clutched the briefcase
tightly and made his way out of the
station his plan had been to call a taxi
but now the prospect of being alone in
an anonymous vehicle with only one other
person terrified him his best protection
would be to stay out in the open as much
as possible he would walk to the British
Embassy or rather he'd pretend to limp
there Lambda 9 operatives number seven
and 8 stood by the helicopter shivering
their team had been missing for hours
now and they could see the blizzard
slowly covering the mountain range like
a blanket before long would reach them
if their helicopter got buried by
anything more than a couple of inches
all hopes of evacuating back to base
would be dashed as soon as their team
had gone through the doors into the
facility all radio contact with them had
been cut off the foundation had
suspected that the bunker would be
heavily insulated but if that were the
case surely one of them would have
stepped outside to resume radio contact
and report what they had found so far
then all of a sudden seven went limp it
remained standing but his head and
shoulders slumped forward as if he'd
fallen asleep perhaps he had been
standing out here for too long Aid was
about to Rouse him when suddenly seven
started talking hello eight can you hear
me it's one are you there the
conversation moved quickly somehow one
had been able to reach out to Seven's
mind and temporarily take control in
order to use him as a mouthpiece to
communicate with the foundation over the
radio this kind of contact would
normally have been well beyond what one
would have been capable of but he
explained that as soon as they had
entered the facility both he and two had
felt their powers growing immeasurably
the foundation asked for a situation
report and one updated them about what
had happened to four trying to escape
through the door he jumped and fell
through the abyss but what was more
sickening was that they had seen for
again all of a sudden they had started
to hear his screams physically not
psionically and he had fallen past them
just off to their right almost within
touching distance having decided decided
that it was too risky to attempt an
escape as four had done the group of
them made the decision to travel further
down into the facility descending along
the Helix for the next 3 hours s is
unresponsive he stands there limp in the
snow hunched forward and not speaking
despite eight and the foundation's best
attempts to wake him command we found
something the Helix branches off a bit
there's a doorway there I can see inside
it looks like a lab of some kind we can
walk to it hopefully it's a way out
command sent authorization for them to
proceed and so they did one reported
that it appeared that they were back in
the real world the abstract shapes and
colors the infinite void was gone they
were in a Soviet research lab there was
medical equipment everywhere syringes
and jars full of well maybe it's best
not to know what was in them as Lambda 9
walked through the facility checking
every corner before rounding out they
felt a profound sense of unease surely
enough that feeling was warranted
rounding the corner one found some human
remains the man appeared to have been a
researcher at one point his brains were
now stretched out and stuck to the walls
like Silly Putty what the hell happened
here safely on British soil the man who
had defected from the Soviet Union sat
in the interview room chewing his bottom
lip he had spent so much time focusing
on how he would escape with his life
that he hadn't spared much thought for
what he would say once he was on the
other side they had codenamed him Iceman
but he didn't feel particularly cold at
that moment he felt nervous but he did
his best to hide it I was a project
manager in the psychotronics division of
the main intelligence directorate I
oversaw project Redline which was
commissioned by Joseph Stalin following
the second world war and before he knew
what he was doing he told his
interviewer everything over 20 million
Soviets had died during the second world
war their death toll eclipsed that of
any other country country Iceman had
witnessed it all so when Stalin had come
to him with the task of creating an
ultra powerful psychic weapon something
that could convert the entire world
population to adopt Marxism leninism the
man had his reservations activating a
device like that could trigger a war
even deadlier than either of the two
already experienced that Century he was
part of Gru division P the Russian arm
of Highly classified experimental
research conferring with this team they
devised a plan they would argue they
needed absolute secrecy to carry out
their work even away from the watching
eyes of the KGB rather than create a
weapon they would create a tool for
peace instead of promoting the values of
Communism they would create a psychic
tool to dampen Humanity's inclination
towards violence and aggression their
method would be brutal but un necessary
evil in short their theory was the
psychic mind is often limited by the
human body a young child could have
incredible psychic potential but their
physical limitations would hold them
back from exercising it therefore they
needed to separate mind from body and
they had just the trick for that
traumatic disassociation they would take
a young gifted psychic and tear out
their mind in order to transfer that
mind into the body of a controllable
Avatar Iceman explained that none of
them could have expected how much fate
would look favorably on them just 2
years prior the k BB had captured and
brought in a set of triplets for them
the triplets were incredibly rare
conjoined at both the head and the Torso
with three arms and six legs it was a
miracle they were still alive so Iceman
and his team set to work immediately
they dosed the triplets up with as many
mind-altering chemicals as they could
physically endure before electrocuting
them for prolonged periods whilst
reading antiv violent manifestos to them
it worked the triplets mind
disassociated and the the Soviets were
able to capture it Iceman was not
forthcoming about what they did with the
mind or where they transferred it all he
explained was that it worked they took
the weapon to the norlock gulock 50,000
of the most vicious criminals known to
men luers murderers Psychopaths dropped
their makeshift knives and refused to
move an inch even as we threw the gates
of the camp wide open we did that the
final test was on Nikita kushev and John
F Kennedy from thousands of kilometers
away they activated project Redline and
influenced the two world leaders at the
height of the Cuban Missile Crisis war
was averted but Kev was Furious he
removed the entire team killing a number
of them and began to weaponize project
Redline if they could fire it at an
advancing Army they'd never lose a
single soldier ever again to do this it
needed to be stronger they were to
implant the Consciousness into another
subject torture them further and
disassociate again amplifying the
psychic abilities mobile task force
Lambda 9 were stuck in the facility the
blizzard had been so strong that seven
and 8 had to return to base the previous
night and come back having spent a night
lost in wandering through the Helix
descending deeper and deeper the team
had noticed that the world around them
was getting darker periodically they
could hear Force screaming and falling
past them once again before dropping out
of sight again beneath them they had
tried to catch him to pull him back but
he was always just Out Of Reach
desperate to be saved s and8 returned
turned and their psychic puppet radio
contact was resumed with command the
team found another door searching
through it they were horrified to find
their own corpses floating in the air in
front of them dressed up in lab coats
just like the scientists from the levels
above them their brains were stretching
out and lying together in some kind of
web yet further down the Helix they
found another door one and three decided
to go inside leaving the rest of the
team standing on the Helix ready to
catch four if he fell past again this
time two was in contact with command
through his psychic link to the men by
the chopper he soon reported hearing
Four's screams getting closer and closer
the group stood around ready to catch
him there he is I can see him he's
definitely Falling Towards us yeah I see
it too command there's something up with
for it looks like he's spread eagled his
arms are stretched out he's he's
screaming it's not getting louder it's
getting flatter there would be no
further contact with two five and six by
the time one and three returned from
scouting out the room there were were
alone one couldn't even sense the
presence of any of their squadmates
anymore they had no option but to
continue to descend the Helix into the
darkness the smell of burning flesh
filled their noses The Echoes of death
were all around them voices cried out in
pain and fear and then new voices
speaking in Russian cut over the top
stop it give in don't resist resisting
is bad you'll be punished if you resist
begin electrical discharge 500 volts 3
amps increase voltage every minute the
operatives had no choice but to listen
to the memory of the triplets being
tortured not just the sounds but the
emotions that flood them those weren't
someone else's memories anymore they
were becoming their own and just as they
saw into the mind of the triplets the
triplets saw them in return command it's
trying to open me up like it did
everyone else but I can see into it it's
learning from us and knows all about me
the squad the foundation they're almost
on me it's it's the conjunction the
scientists the monsters that made this
thing the ones it knew before it died
was that they wanted it to conjunct it
wants to make us part of it don't come
back here it wants to make the whole
world part of it and at that moment the
entirety of mobile task force Lambda 9
dropped dead in that same moment a
multicolored sphere of energy 5 km wide
appeared over the fac facility dwarfing
the mountains around it designated SCP
2664 daa for years the foundation
dropped psionically dampening materials
and psionically stumped d-class
Personnel into the sphere in hopes of
slowing its growth no other containment
measures could be acted upon that was
until 1300 hours on the 25th of December
2000 Christmas Day SCP 2664 daa suddenly
fluctuated releasing an enormous amount
of psionic energy that resulted Ed in
the brain death of all humans within a
200 km radius the following day at 1700
hours a global cult Coalition satellite
launched a spherical payload right into
the heart of SCP 2664 daa for 13 minutes
tremendous amounts of radiation were
detected emanating from inside the
sphere before just as suddenly as it had
appeared SCP 2664 daa disappeared
entirely leaving just the payload in its
place before the the foundation was able
to recover the payload it launched into
the atmosphere and was lost subsequent
reconnaissance operations to the site
have confirm no abnormal radioactive or
psionic readings to all intents and
purposes SCP 2664 appears to be gone as
such the file has been marked as
neutralized long may it stay that way
now check out SCP 407 Unit 731 and SCP
186 to end all wars